this is Jocko podcast number 396 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
according to the Marine Corps
quote physical fitness includes a set of
characteristics that people have or can
achieve relating to their ability to
perform physical activity our service
members must demonstrate the ability to
physically accomplish all aspects of the
mission while remaining healthy and meet
the criteria for deployment retention
and continued military service
many components of physical fitness are
shared across the services the Common
Thread among them is that service
members and their families benefit from
a holistic approach to physical fitness
a well-rounded physical fitness program
should include varied cardio training
balance to strength training that
includes core strengthening exercises
flexibility Speed and Agility training
appropriate amounts of sleep and
recovery and effective mind-body
programs such as yoga martial arts and
meditation
physical fitness is a fundamental
element of one's physical and mental
health Mission performance
and readiness end quote
and that is what the Marine Corps
says about physical fitness and similar
statements to that are made by all the
military branches and Special Operations
these ideas are taken to an extreme in
many cases but these
philosophies are not only applicable to
the military
the same things can be said for
any human being in any Walk of Life it
is better to be stronger faster and
healthier
than there are always
people out there and companies and
movements that try and share this
mentality and help people find this path
of health and one of those movements
and really one of the most prominent of
those movements is CrossFit which is a
methodology that's made a huge impact on
people around the world and continues to
help people to get on that path to
improve physically and in all those
other aspects
and Crossfit right now currently
is being led by a veteran Marine
infantry officer who graduated from the
United States Naval Academy who served
in both Iraq and Afghanistan
got his MBA from Stanford
worked at some little tech companies
like Google Facebook and Pinterest
his name is Don fall and it's an honor
to have him here with us tonight to
share his experiences and his lessons
learned along the way
Don thanks for coming down man thanks
for joining us thanks for having me guys
the honors mine yeah pretty uh pretty
wild little story you've been on little
wild ride you've been on never would
have predicted I from the Marine Corps
to Pinterest I say Marine Corps to
cupcakes and ponytails so you can't
write it we're gonna have to we might
have to dive into Pinterest a little bit
because that's the one social media
thing that I I don't really get too well
not made for people like you let's leave
it at that okay and then what bothers me
is I'll search an image and I'll wanna
and one of their images will pop up and
they I won't be able to get it for some
reason you know what I mean it's telling
me to sign in with something once again
by Design yeah they're trying to they
know you're coming
awesome well we'll get there uh in the
meantime let's let's I was like to start
at the beginning which is how you got to
where you are so you were born in what
in New Jersey so yeah little town called
Allendale uh right outside New York City
about 15 miles uh Bergen County New
Jersey is it so New Jersey is it far
enough to be in the woods or is it City
supper like full-on suburbs in New York
City yep because there's places like the
Pine Barrens that are full on Woods in
New Jersey people don't think of oh yeah
I mean New Jersey Garden State most
people scoff at that but there are big
parts of the state that are beautiful
yeah and then there's the Jersey Shore
of this course as well so there's a lot
of variety in Jersey but you're in a
straight up suburb straight up suburb of
New York City and what'd your parents do
so my dad was a environmental engineer
back in the 80s like early days so when
the EPA was first established started
cracking down on companies my dad worked
for a company that would take process
waste uh toxic waste and process it my
mom was a nurse so she uh you know went
to nursing school as a nurse until uh
she got pregnant with me and did you
have any veterans in your family I had
an uncle who had been drafted in Vietnam
but was never talked about I had both my
grandfather served for a short period of
time during World War II but also it was
never a topic of conversation so I grew
up in in a family in in a town where MO
service was not a thing and I remember
when I when I was talking to my parents
about this the other day when I decided
to go to the Naval Academy I remember
friends of mine asking me like hey what
happened I thought your parents could
afford College my mom was telling me
several of my teachers called her and
said how could you let your son do this
yeah which is really unfortunate
that's why so before you before you go
to the academy you're growing up what
are you doing in high school are you
playing sports you're playing all sports
what are you doing I was I was super
into sports as a kid unfortunately not
really great at any of them uh played
football basketball baseball soccer uh
really wanted to be an athlete and uh
but was never great I knew I had no shot
of playing at the next level so I I
graduated it's funny Castro Dave Castro
and I have a really similar story I
graduated high school with a chip on my
shoulder because I was Never As Good an
athlete as I wanted to be did you train
hard uh I would say I was I was somewhat
disciplined but I didn't really learn
true discipline until I went to the
Naval Academy and what about just the
training programs back then I mean there
wasn't like didn't exist now kids now
they're going to like
special camps so they can work on their
freaking forehand for tennis they're
doing their three-week camp for
beforehand and Dennis they're doing a
three-week camp for single leg takedowns
like they're getting real specific with
these kids oh and they've got they've
got multiple coaches on the side who are
training them and strength and
conditioning who are doing mental
training no that was that was not the
thing for me uh obviously uh no I you
know I uh you know played High School
sports and you know our our football
coach was our you know gym teacher that
was the standard thing and you know
that's where I learned to do the bench
press and bicep curls which was the
extent of my strength conditioning
training for the next 15 years oh yeah
um so I didn't really learn any of this
until I got further down the road what
were your grades like I had good grades
I was uh I had pretty decent grades were
you uh what what else were you into what
about music what music were you
listening I was a disaster much to my
parents grid I play oh listen to well I
was gosh going way back so I was a huge
Bruce Springsteen I mean being from New
Jersey obviously they issue those albums
I wish I wish or something the tattoos
when you turn you know 13.
um Big John Mellencamp fan Bob Seger uh
and then the full 80s crazy so I was a
you know a child of the 80s and still an
adult of the 80s it's when I when I
train now in the mornings I beg the
coaches to put the 80s mix on
everyone else hates it and so so at some
point though you figured out you saw the
naval cat how did you see the naval cat
yeah I got exposed to it actually there
was a weekend visit when I was a junior
in high school and I was thinking a
little bit you know my parents
definitely drummed into me the
importance of service so I you know I
volunteer with the ambulance Corps as an
EMT when I was in high school and my you
know did Boy Scouts for a short stint so
my parents were really big on giving
back you know we knew growing up that we
were very fortunate and so my parents
you know certainly emphasize service and
so I went checked out the Naval Academy
I thought something in the military
might be interesting uh went down for a
weekend had absolutely
zero exposure to the military before
this no understanding of what I was
getting myself into but I remember going
down for the weekend and just being
struck by how fundamentally different it
was from every other college experience
so the other visits that I did and it
totally clicked to me so I came back
from that and said this is my thing this
feels really hard I have no idea if I'll
want to do this for the rest of my life
I'm 17 I don't know anything but even if
you know I do my five years after
graduation and get out I will have had
exposure to a bunch of Life Experiences
that'll be good for me did you
understand the difference between the
Navy and the Marine Corps no not at all
and when I went to I really did my
homework I mean it's not like it was a
big decision I was just committing a
decade of My Life
um yeah so I showed up and I thought you
know if you had asked me on day one I
would have said I wanted to be a
backseat pilot I didn't have the eyes to
be a pilot so I thought oh maybe I'll be
a naval flight officer backseater
um you know and then got to the Naval
Academy and got exposed to you know they
expose you to each of the different uh
parts of the Navy and the Marine Corps
and you know once I experienced the
Marine Corps click how was the the
check-in plebe summer and all that stuff
was it a shock to the system did you
have uh
in the first 48 hours did you think what
why did I do this oh within an hour so I
I remember first day they call it
induction day and they you know they
structure it right it's a shock to the
system just like the first day of any
Boot Camp or basic training but you know
they shave your head uh put you in line
take all of your possessions away right
the standard stuff and then they start I
remember we had a session where we could
say goodbye to our parents and then you
walk back into there's one big dorm that
everybody lives in four thousand people
in one dorm and up until this point the
pressure was like a six and a half and
then we walk in the door to go back to
the dorm and then it's a full 12 and I
remember just if I had any hair it would
have been blown back at that point and
you know by the end of that first day
I I was really you know giving it second
thoughts I uh I I was in complete uh you
know paralyzed Retreat mode you know
they structure it it's very obvious now
where you you can't succeed right like
you you deliberately fail and everything
making your bed your uniform Etc I had
never been in that type of environment
before I was used to things common
relatively easy to me and I just could
not deal with it and then I remember on
my my second day it clicked I was like
dumbass you're not supposed to succeed
you just got to make it through you just
got to keep your together and that
at that point it got a little bit easier
for me so once you get into so plebe
summer you go through how long is how
long are they messing with you in bleep
somewhere is that like six weeks or is
it the whole summer it is it's the whole
summer and actually you're you know they
mess with you for the full first year so
it's most intense for the for the summer
and then the rest of the uh class the
Brigade comes back and you get treated
like through the end through May of
your uh year
and are you doing sports because you
have to do sports right so you do you
have to do some sort of activity so you
know if you're not a varsity athlete
they make you go out and do something
else again I had no shot of being a
varsity athlete there and I had an uncle
actually who was a rower total stud and
you know I really admired him so I went
Navy's got a good crew team so I went
out there for like a couple days I'm
like I'll go give rowing a shot I give
that about three days I think this sucks
a lot
um uh I have a lot of admiration for
rowers because you gotta you gotta love
suffering in that sport um it just
didn't click with me the culture didn't
click with me and then I had an upper
class this was fall in my first year it
came in my room he was a junior and he
said hey do you play sports in high
school I said yeah yes sir and he said
you played a sport here I said no he
said you're playing rugby show up
tomorrow and that was it there was no
choice and so I was like geez you know I
had never thought of it before I didn't
know a single thing about it hadn't
watched a game in my life showed up and
that was my thing I played for four
years uh you know thank God for that
moment are are they playing against
other colleges is it like a D1 D2 D3
type thing they have a whole nine yards
it is it back then it was uh largely a
club sport so every school but Cal
Berkeley was Club sport but we played
you know Mid-Atlantic regions we'd play
Georgetown Loyola Catholic Etc and then
they'd have a whole National Finals kind
of playoff system as well and the
Berkeley Bears just got to be League
Champs because they were the only ones
it was such and their their
coach I mean they won the national
championship for something like 18 years
in a row their head coach at Cal was
also the U.S national team head coach so
they just had the deck stack but they
were they were really really good Shack
uh so what would you end up studying so
I studied systems engineering which is
kind of a control weapon systems thing
was this something that interested you
because you're like why the would
you do that
um yeah I would say uh I would say more
of a math and science guy I didn't
didn't like uh you know the language
arts as much the the math and
Engineering stuff resonated my dad was
an engineer and so for me as a kid that
was something that I had always aspired
to it just made sense it made sense and
I enjoyed it actually and then at what
point did you hear about the Marine
Corps so after my after plebe year
um every summer you basically get sent
out to get exposure to a different part
of of the fleet of the naval service so
for summer
um I think it was first after the first
summer did a little bit with the Navy
and they did a month down in Quantico
with the Marines and after a week there
totally resonated you know as you know
every service has a slightly different
culture and the culture in the Marine
Corps just really resonated with me
how hard is it to get a Marine Corps
slot from the Naval Academy so it's it's
varied a ton over the years
um I I think I can't remember if all the
slots went out there was a period of
time during which they had to force
people to go Marine Corps so there'd be
slots left over and then I think after
post 911 I can't remember my year
whether all the slots went out or not
but post 911 they were really sought
after so it was a really competitive
thing I think it's somewhere between 17
to 20 of Naval Academy grads going to
the Marines
and when you're at the Naval Academy
Looking Back Now what are you learning
from a leadership perspective there oh
gosh
um you know I think first and foremost
the biggest thing I learned really early
on was how to think about others and not
myself
you know I grew up as a kid you know
going to school even playing sports to
some degree the first orientation is
like you know thinking about myself am I
in the in the bright spot or my grades
good Etc and you know that for summer
you learn you know it doesn't matter if
your room looks good if your buddy's
room doesn't look good like and that was
such a foreign concept to me when they
asked me why is so and so jacked up ask
him why are you talking to me that
mindset shift was massive for me so like
really learning what it means to be a
great follower in service of
understanding how to be a great leader
was formative for me there yeah at some
point I'm gonna have one of my roommates
from buds on this podcast and he's going
to tell the story about we had a room
inspection and a you know bed inspection
and a locker inspection and a knife
inspection so our knives you know we had
to be sharp and rust free and all this
stuff and I of course was super militant
about everything and doing everything
and we I'd spend all weekend just
sharpening my knife and polishing my
boots and all this stuff and so
the instructor comes in and picks up my
knife and they would shave their arm
with your knife you know and if it could
shave their arm it's a pass and so he
takes my knife and shaves arms he's like
you know basically good job and then he
grabs my buddy's knife and it's just
dull as hell and so and I've I'm
thinking like I'm you know pretty much
awesome right and the instructor's like
yeah he's like what's up with you buddy
he couldn't even couldn't even
help your friend and he takes my knife
we had the bunk beds with the there's
like a metal rod across the bottom and
he takes my knife and just like straight
into this Rod like like 10 times there's
just big giant like c-shaped divots on
the whole knife you know and then I had
to go hit the surf so yeah you learn
pretty quickly that just taking care of
yourself is is not going to work out too
well yeah and then on the summer cruises
so once you decided you're going to the
Marine Corps did you go to do something
with the Marines every summer uh I did
let's see yes so you know following
summer then so after your sophomore year
um and I'm probably screwing up years
here I think I did every summer
something with the Marines I did that
that initial session and then I went
back for an intense a month where you
did a month in Quantico and then I did
another month in the fleet so you would
do a couple of weeks I did a couple
weeks with a ground unit and then a
couple weeks with an aviation Squadron
that was after my my junior year uh to
then set up uh graduation did the dream
of being a pilot or a backseat or just
die some at some point yeah it did it
did I I I didn't have any interest you
know two reasons I didn't have interest
in
um
the and being a backseater for me I you
know it was for me front seat or nothing
and and actually just you know being an
infantry Marine infantry leader really
resonated with me how bad was your
vision real bad did you get Lasix I
actually got PRK when I was in the Navy
okay uh so it was like 2400 something
like that in my left eye real bad did
you you got that while you're at the
Naval Academy I got that actually on
active duty right at Balboa check so you
decide to go Marine Corps and you get
selected and then once you get selected
you graduate you graduated by the way I
got to make a mention you know you
graduated with a bunch of people we have
a bunch of uh mutual friends because
we're we're actually in the same officer
year group so like all the Naval Academy
guys that graduated in 1998 I was in the
same year group because that's when I
got commissioned was in 1998 including a
bunch of mutual friends that we have and
then Leif uh Leif Babin he was also part
of that year group
um
so you graduate and then it's basic
school that's right yep so down to
Quantico I spent almost just under a
year in Quantico so all Marine officers
go through this basic school so you know
the philosophy of a marina Rifleman
where it doesn't matter what you do
you're gonna go learn how to be an
infantry Marine do you know you're going
to be an infantry officer when you go to
the basic School you do not so you know
you're either ground or air contract and
then while you're at the basic school
about two-thirds of the way through they
stack rank the class you put in a bunch
of lists and then you get assigned your
MLS yeah and they do that by what what
do they call that system where it's
quality spread quality spread very
controversial yeah so they cut it in
thirds they start from one you know up
to the top of the first third yeah to me
whenever people want to ask me about the
Marine Corps and they want to get some
details about why the Marine Corps
squared away
I will talk I will talk to them about
quality spread because there's nothing
that you could do
as an organization that could more
clearly show that what is important to
the Marine Corps is the entire Marine
Corps then quality spread so quality
spread Echo Charles what they do is they
got 100 people in the class
they cut it up into thirds and the first
person in the first group gets the first
pick
the first person in the second group
gets the second pick the first person in
the third group this is this is ranked
on order of achievement so you could be
a really really great person and still
get one of the last picks you could be
in the top third of the class and get
one of the last picks in the class
so that's a but it shows that the Marine
Corps puts the Marine Corps above the
individual hallways without question
when you're at the basic School
was there any challenges that you faced
oh for sure yeah what was hard
um I mean you know a new level of I'd
say that that was the first time I
really got exposure to uh you know being
in the field and and playing even though
you're you're leading peers doing it
under quasi-adverse conditions hadn't
really been exposed to that at the Naval
Academy per se so you know being sleep
deprived being out in the colds um
trying to motivate a bunch of peers who
many of whom could get you know if
they're gonna go be an admin officer a
pilot could give two shits about how the
Patrol's going
um so you know keeping folks motivated
and focused was a was a real challenge
how much time do you spend in the field
there
in the basic school so we did did TBS
first
um I'd say gosh probably maybe
maybe 10 of the time you do a lot of
class stuff and then I did infantry
officer course after that so all the
info officers then once you get your MOS
you go to your secondary specialty
school and basic school is like six
months right correct and how long is
infantry officer I think I'll see these
12 weeks I think it's three months
then you so you get in there and what do
you what do you what are your challenges
when when you get to infantry Officer
school so infantry officer course takes
uh most of it I'd say you know much
higher percentage time is in the field
uh the bar is much higher in terms of
kind of leadership uh ratcheting up in
terms of the adversity around you know
sleep food deprivation cold that's all
dialed up and then you're learning a
bunch of you know strategy and tactics
um employed under pressure again for the
first time so just lots of lots of
mistakes on that front lots of learnings
again surrounded by your peers all of
whom now you've got it you know a bunch
of infantry officers so you know within
this cohort of officers the most
probably type a uh and learning how to
lead uh in that group was was definitely
a big big challenge
I had James Webb on the podcast and he
went through his you know he did the
same thing Academy
Basic School infantry officer course
nine days leave or something like this
straight to Vietnam gets to Vietnam they
take him out like in a jeep they point
to a Ridgeline and they say your
platoon's up there on that Ridge line he
walks up to this Ridge line
uh there's no officer to relieve because
the officer had been wounded or killed
there's some Sergeant that's been
running the platoon he takes over the
platoon that night they get into a
significant fire fight he has to call
for fire and I said did you feel like
you were prepared and he looked at me
and said I was prepared so that's that's
pretty pretty freaking outstanding that
you can take someone that's never been
in combat before and the day the night
they arrive in combat they're doing
significant call for fire and that that
shows you once again the Marine Corps is
squared away
entity without question no doubt yeah
TBS was a great school ioc was
outstanding the curriculum the Cadre the
leadership the program in that you know
relatively short time period they got
you about as ready as they could do you
do a lot of live fire you do a lot of
live fire there how about force on Force
training with like either paintball or
laser I we didn't I don't think we did
it back then that that probably has
changed in the meantime I I know it's
definitely changed
um it changed in the Seal team so what
is this what year is this 90
90 99.99 so yeah that's that's around
when we really started going very very
heavy with force on Force training in
the SEAL Teams with simunition with
laser tech we got a did you ever use
dits no sorry not debts what's the old
one uh I forget what it's called but
there's an old laser system that the
whole military used to use yeah we used
that in the fleet a little bit yeah and
it's not good no it's terrible yeah yeah
so we got a system that was super high
speed and it really allowed us to
come as close to simulated combat
and that I can think you could get to uh
it was just awesome and it really helped
us in the SEAL Teams get better at
everything you know it's really easy to
assault a Target
filled with paper targets that don't
move and don't shoot back yep when those
when those targets are moving around
running and flanking you and shooting
back it you have to figure out you have
to you have to really learn leadership
and that's what we found that that's how
we were able to start to improve our
leadership was by putting people in
pressure situations and having the enemy
do what the enemy is going to do yep so
so then where where did you head so you
graduate obviously so I graduated I got
stationed out of Ken Pendleton so I got
uh assigned to a unit called first Force
Recon or sorry First Light Armored
reconnaissance Battalion so it was a
mechanized infantry effectively
um now I got assigned to a platoon of 30
Marines four armored vehicles these
light armored vehicles they look like a
Bradley but have wheels so big 25
millimeter Bushmaster Cannon pretty
badass
um less walking so I got a lot of
from the straight leg infantry that it
was a real infantry
um yeah and so showed up at my first
command you know thinking you know after
four years the Naval Academy you're in
Quantico that I knew what I was doing
and then cold reality at me in the face
when I got my first platoon
30 guys in your first platoon and you're
going to be on deployment you're going
on on like an arc deployment or what was
the situation so it would have been a
mute and uh we had some time I think out
about a year and a half before uh you
know chop into the Mew so I had some
time but I came into it you know I came
into a platoon you know normally as a
brand new second Lieutenant you come in
you've got a seasoned staff NCO who
basically unfucks you right and teaches
you the job I came into a unit with 30
uh Lance corporals I had two newly
promoted Corporal so super junior ncos
that was it how come it just happened to
be at this point I think this unit had
just come off the Muse he had a bunch of
folks rotating out they hadn't fully
staffed it up yet and so truly the blind
leading the blind again showed up on day
one and I was like holy and first I
was very fortunate in that my first
commanding officer first comedy
Commander was Prior enlisted exceptional
and read me the right act after about
two weeks and then I I was very
fortunate got assigned a super Seasons
uh Sergeant platoon Sergeant who was a
retread so he had been a sniper marine
sniper during the first Gulf War had
gotten out and then came back in and
basically taught me the job
and so then you go through a workup go
through a workup so I spent some time
with that unit
um go through a full workup deployment
uh and then chop to the MU you go
through yeah basically the mute workup
cycle about six months and then I
deployed in uh we left in August of
2001. oh dang yep when you're in this
position this is something that gets
talked about leadership all the time
um you're in this position you're
obviously not experienced and yet you're
in charge
what are some of the mindsets that you
and some of the strategies you used when
trying to lead
these you know these marines the you
know I mentioned I had I was really
lucky to have this pretty amazing
commanding officer and he he after a
couple he's called me in and asked me
the question you never want to get how
do you think it's going
you're like oh
um and so I you know I can't even
remember what I said to him but he
basically said you need to stop running
around and trying to do your brains jobs
for them your job's to lead you need to
give them the space to make mistakes so
I'd come out of this uh you know World
growing up or the Naval Academy were
largely my performance was within my
control my grades even military
performance at the Naval Academy there's
a little bit of leadership but it's
largely how you show up
and I show up here wanting everything to
be done well because I've got a high bar
a high standard I don't I haven't
learned yet what it means to lead under
those conditions and so I was
micromanaging the out of my Marines
and we were failing everywhere and so I
had a very tough very necessary
conversation from the CEO saying you
need to give your Marines the space to
learn and make some make mistakes and
thank God for that lesson
um so that was a really big one for me
of of but it was still hard honestly
like I was not wired to be comfortable
with mistakes and things not going well
so you know being able to to get a
little more comfortable with that give
my Marines a little bit of space make
mistakes was a really big uh big
learning experience for me yeah I've
been explaining that to people quite a
bit lately when you use decentralized
command there's risk involved there's
risk involved that hey the people that
are on the front lines they might do
nine things right and that feels great
and that 10 thing might not be quite
what you would have done it might even
be a little bit outside the box and and
if you decide okay well you see
decentralized command doesn't work out
you just need to control everything then
you're going to get back to the point
which is what you just talked about
which is another thing people have a
hard time understanding
you can't control everything yeah
there's no way you can control 30
Marines in a gunfight you can't do it
you can barely control them you know
loading up of ship so if you think
you're gonna be able to control
everything in a pressure situation
you're not going to be able to you have
to develop young leaders you have to you
have decentralized command you have to
be able to let go and it's hard yep and
you have to learn how to create Clarity
for people and that's not telling them
what to do it's it's making sure they
have the context making sure they've got
the intent what does success look like
make sure they have the skills making
sure they're getting feedback when they
make mistakes that was just a completely
new skill set for me I had never learned
to experience that
it's interesting that in five years
through the Naval Academy and then basic
school and then infantry officer course
it wasn't quite there yet
for sure I'll be honest it's still not
quite there yet like remain a work in
progress Jack
so you're you go on deployment in August
2001 yep now is this a shipboard
deployment it is yeah so this is a this
is a muse you've got you know call it 3
000 Marines get a board Navy ships at
this point so this is yeah this is 2001
and so up until this point it was a go
see the world it was go to Australia go
to the you know uh go to the Far East uh
get some cool little uh ports and come
back and obviously that changed what
ship did you Deploy on I was in the USS
pelaloo oh I did a cruise with the
police yes I had a good weight room what
was it I wasn't on the pal Lou
unfortunately I was on one of the I
think I was on the either the Cleveland
the USS Cleveland or the USS Denver
which did not have that nice of a waiver
but we did the best we could Echo you
would be happy we brought a cruise box
and in the cruise box we had dumbbells
and we had
120s 110s
like 100s 90s and 80s and then the ship
had the rest but obviously we didn't
carry the cruise box and one but we we
brought the cruise box and we locked the
cruise box and then if the Marines were
the cool Marines we'd give them a combo
what's the cruise box it's just like a
big like floor Locker it's like a it's
like a treasure chest oh damn just made
a metal it's the heaviest yeah I'm gonna
get a forklift or something no no we
we've loaded them individually yeah
individual breakup
so you're out there on deployment August
were you did you make it overseas by
September yeah so we you know we headed
out straight from left from San Diego
um went to Australia so went to
Australia and we did a week of training
in Darwin so up in crocodile country up
in the north with the Australian Army we
had a week out in the fields came back
first night off first night off since we
had left San Diego it's almost a month
so as you can imagine Marines are to the
winds
uh I think it was 10 o'clock at night
and I remember being in an Irish Pub
because there's Irish Pub everywhere
around the world and watch 911 on TV
through this Haze of you know X number
of beers that we had had at that point
then what happens so we yeah you call
everybody as quickly it was it was this
insane trying to recall 3000 Marines
from across Darwin to you know to leave
the next morning at zero seven
um we I think we got everybody but one
or two marines they had to meet us
they were doing uh something that shall
not be disclosed and uh so they they you
know flew ahead and eventually met us
and we headed out we actually went to
East to Moore
um so if you remember there's a little
bit of uh some ethnic cleansing issues
there and so we were doing some
humanitarian stuff we spent three days
there and then we headed straight for
the early main sea at that point and
then where were you going so we we ended
up um sitting off the coast of Pakistan
and so this is probably now gosh
uh late October of 2001
um starting to do the planning for the
invasion and so we did the Mew basically
we we took uh our hovercraft into little
town a little Air Force Base in southern
Pakistan and then flew from Pakistan
into Southern Afghanistan just outside
qandar how was the how was the attitude
of the troops
I'd say uh you know a mix of excited
anxious afraid but not willing to admit
it
um lots of uh lots of speculation I
remember one morning you know one of the
other platoon commanders came in and
said I heard this morning that Congress
declared war on Iran were like holy
Jesus this just got real fortunately
that turned out not to be true
um and then it was just like get ready
you know I think there was the nervous
anticipation what was your what was your
tasking so we uh originally so we did a
little bit of planning for a while they
were looking at we thought we might have
to do an evacuation of the U.S consulate
in Karachi that didn't go down
um fortunately our tasking was we flew
into a little Airfield called rhino in
the middle of uh just about probably 60
miles south of Kandahar I think we flew
into there and then we drove into
Kandahar and secured the Kandahar
Airfield and then that became a hub
where we started bringing in uh you know
other conventional units humanitarian
supplies and we essentially did security
operations ends in and around Konda
horror looking for you know Al Qaeda
Taliban what was the atmospherics on the
ground when you get when you got there I
mean at this point they were super
disorganized it was it was uh surreal I
remember you know we drove we landed in
this Airfield where there was no one and
then we drove through the desert didn't
see a person and then as we started
getting closer we were literally just
driving through farms and these little
mud Huts right as you see over there and
you know we had a translator with us and
you remember talking and they're like oh
yeah we haven't seen these in uh it's
been 20 years since the Russians were
here but so there's an element of like
we've seen this movie before and uh and
then you know a lot of uh I'd say kind
of you know uncertainty around what was
happening in
um in and around uh condor
so you're where where are you based in
kind of hard at the Airfield yeah so we
secured the Airfield we were basically
sitting in fighting holes around the
perimeter of the Airfield how are you
what are you eating uh MREs how long are
you in there for we were there for I
think about three months
once you have the Airfield secured now
are you they send you out on patrols to
go make contact with the Taliban they
send you out to make contact with the
local villagers like what was a little
bit of both yeah so we did a little bit
of it was security operations in and
around the kind of Hub of the Airfield
so we would do a mix of just going out
and trying to gather information
intelligence
um so talking to local farmers and
villagers about what was happening there
were a couple
um a couple interdiction operations
um around one of the major highways that
Randy's trying to trying to catch some
of the uh Taliban leadership that was
still there were you thinking about IEDs
really
we uh we were not but we had a an
unfortunately we had a couple Marines
step on a land mine at the Airfield so
there were you know I don't know how
many thousands of landmines there from
who knows when they could have been
Soviet era and unfortunately we had a
marine step on one and he fortunately
survived but lost part of his lower leg
so that that changed the calculus really
quick for folks but that you were
looking at as if it was some old it
could have been something we didn't know
you didn't really know like uh maybe the
towel man left at this time or maybe
it's just been here for 25 30 years
because you would drive you know if as
you drive around there you'd have these
villagers would Mark the the minefields
in the area they put white rocks there
for cleared minefields and red rocks for
ones that were not cleared
um and so you would just you'd see old
Ordnance sticking out of these Farms it
you know it was crazy yeah it's I I got
to kind of see the escalation in Iraq I
didn't fight in Afghanistan but in Iraq
you know between my first between like
2003 2004 2006 like the escalation of
the threat of the IEDs when went crazy
and in Afghanistan
was worse in a lot of ways um from what
I can tell the the way it went from sort
of like IEDs weren't really a thing and
when they happened you're like oh it
might have been some also to you know
this is an absolute horror show that we
have to be completely paranoid about
every every step we take yeah we were
lucky I I think we were we were there at
a time where it was very offensive for
us
they were it was still very early so
there wasn't much of an organized
counter-offensive at all so we didn't
have to really think about or deal with
those issues and then what was your op
Tempo like was it going out every night
was going out every other night we were
going out I'd say probably once a day
um for kind of limited work in and
around the area but it wasn't crazy
and then it's back MREs did you have any
like bathrooms shower facilities
anything like that we did not big
negative big negative and I will say I
got the the privilege there of serving
General Mattis was the Task Force
Commander uh amazing so he he actually
came and he met us in the middle of the
desert and rode in with us on our lead
he insisted on being the lead lab
driving into Kandahar what was his job
he was the task he got appointed task
force 58 Commander hell yeah amazing so
he uh he came in with us
um and he was I mean as it like what an
extraordinary guy I remember so many
moments from you know we were our
Marines were sleeping in fighting holes
uh they had the headquarters element in
the terminal uh we had a bunch of Air
Force come in of course the headquarters
element gets the terminal well but
General Mattis early on he said not one
of my nobody will sleep on cots for a
marine sleeping in the dirt you will
sleep in the dirt
um Marines will cold weather gear not a
single senior leader will get cold
weather gear and wear it until
everything single Junior Marine has it
he personally supervised it you'd hear
stories I would walk the lines at night
you know doing the check on my Marines
and more you know frequently General
Mattis would be there two in the morning
sitting next to a lance corporal you
know talking to him about where he's
from and you know asking a very
thoughtful questions around hey what's
your mission and you know it wasn't just
getting to know him he was inspecting us
as well
um but you know that is a guy
that Marines would walk through fire for
hell yeah
so
any significant events that that left an
impact on you as a leader there
I was
I I remember at the time having this
moment of you know I think when you're
in a for me at least I felt like you've
got the the privilege of being in
command because it on on for a host of
reasons but
um being in a position where you had the
the ability to think about others first
so you almost didn't have that I didn't
have as much time to think about I mean
I was scared of course I was but but
being in a position where my first every
day was let me make sure my Marine is
taken care of are they focusing on the
right things that was a really big
um uh takeaway for me as well as
you know like as we know like at the end
of the day my Marines were largely 18
and 19 year old kids kids who were I had
a marine who was six months out of high
school
you know these are kids and seeing how
they showed up under the most stressful
and adverse of circumstances
man what a privilege to get a chance to
witness that
yeah the amount of responsibility that
some Lance corporal has sitting out in a
fighting position making decisions that
only he is going to be able to make at
that moment in time
it's it's it's in freaking pretty
amazing thing to witness it is it is
so
how do you guys redeploy out of that
situation do they do they fly you on
helicopters back to the ship or
something we flew on I think we flew on
c-17s back I can't remember uh oh we
flew to Bahrain so I think we flew on
c-17's out to Bahrain and then
redeployed from there uh back out to the
ship and
is it what what year so it's still
that's early 2002 yeah oh yeah exactly
so did you feel like we kind of just did
it
I know like my first deployment to Iraq
2003 got back in 2004 got home in 2004.
I felt like man I'm lucky I got to do
this like this war is going to be over
soon and you know we'll all carry on
with the rest of our careers did you
have that feeling for sure yeah and we
we you know we were lucky in that I just
happened to be on deployment so when I
got back we were the only Marines in the
Marine Corps who had served in combat
for 20 years yeah and so you know came
back from that we got relieved by an
army unit and uh so I you know I got I
came back transitioned to to my
follow-on unit and and you know thought
that was it
I bet you had that Combat Action Revenue
that's right big time eating a lot of
MREs or in that combat actually so so
then then then you went to uh first
force is that right I did yeah so I I
when I got back I transitioned over to
First Force and and then I went into a
school's phase so force does you know
you do an infantry tour most folks will
come out of the Infantry and then go to
force and then they'll do all their
schooling so you know we have a I don't
know what they do now what they call it
but we had a basic reconnaissance course
dive School reconcourse in Coronado was
that that's right yeah at the amphibase
yeah so we did a three-month uh course
there I went to dive School in Panama
City wait how's the how's that Recon
course it was great it was great yeah I
enjoyed it is it uh indoctrination like
beat down situation are they teaching
you they they're a little bit of both
it's uh probably 50 50. it's hard you
know it's definitely some suffering but
it's it's not like buds because they've
already been uh I don't think so I don't
think we had anybody quit
is it hard to get selected to go to
force week or was it because yes as you
know on the officer side the Marine
Corps you know back then we only had
there's only three forced recon company
size elements in the entire Marines and
each of them probably has three or four
platoon commanders so at any given time
there might be one or two open billets
for officers company grade officers in
the Marine Corps so a lot of it is
timing you know you know it does that
line up for you and then they had a mix
of you know you've got a physical test
and then some interviews that you do as
well did you cross the physical test or
what I did I did well on part of it I
uh almost did not pass the swim actually
there was a a rifle Carriage rifle toe
and my form was on it and I I did
like the last 10 meters underwater
um breath hold just gotten it throughout
so yeah but you had obviously you had a
good record and you'd been in combat and
you were like the first people on the
ground I mean yeah I was lucky I was
lucky and I was really fortunate to have
I had a battalion XO executive officer
at my uh first unit that was great
mentor and advocate for me so he went
out on limb to write letters of
recommendation he talked to the monitor
he talked to uh to the company about
making sure that I was spot lined up are
you thinking about Marine Corps for life
at this point I'm probably I I didn't
think I would serve for life but I was
open-minded around when so going to
force the Marine Corps has this
philosophy where they want to build
really well-rounded officers so you know
unlike some of the other Services even
on you know on the force Recon side as
an officer you could not spend your
career there you could do a company
grade tour for maybe three years if
you're lucky and then maybe you come
back and command one of the three units
as a as an o5 Lieutenant Colonel that's
it and so I knew that I you know going
to that unit was also kind of a strike
against you in terms of the career path
because they'd say actually if you want
to be well-rounded instead of going to
force you should go do a recruiting tour
you should go learn this other side of
the Marine Corps I personally didn't
have any interest in doing that and I
knew going to force that it probably
meant it was a little bit of a step back
but I I didn't have aspirations of
staying in for my career but I wasn't
you know I also didn't say hey I'm going
to get out after the story I was kind of
look as long as I love what I'm doing
I'll stick around that was the game plan
so you go to the am the the Recon school
and then you go to dive School yep is
dive School hard for you since you suck
at swimming it was hard for me I'm uh do
you actually suck at swimming I I do
suck I am comfortable in the water water
but in terms of like stroke and speed
I'm awful and I got really unlucky
actually because
um I show up there and you know they
pair you with the swim buddy and the way
they Parry the swim buddy is they have
everybody swim and then they just go by
speed okay and I was a decent swimmer
not a really good swimmer and then so I
ended up second in our class in terms of
speed the number one guy was a former uh
competitive swimmer uh lifeguard in
Hawaii uh Iron Man triathlete total stud
not the guy you want is your swim buddy
that you're tied to when you're doing
these underwater swims and he dragged my
ass all over Panama City it was brutal
so wait I said you sucked at swimming
and you were number two in the class
yeah but I didn't say there weren't that
many of us that were great swimmers we
had one guy that was great I was enough
to kind of get by I could get my way
through it do you learn closed circuit
when you're down there yes okay so this
is you get your full diving package
you're going to be a full-fledged combat
swimmer that's when you get done with
that and then what do you go to Airborne
after that uh so you should normally you
go to Airborne you go to Airborne then
you go to free fall but I got pulled out
at that point of my school's phase go to
Kuwait so this is now end of 2002 and
they say hey just kidding on Airborne
why don't you come back do a really
quick work up with your platoon and then
deploy to Kuwait I think we deployed in
maybe February of 2002.
February of 2002 is that right no 2003
because now they're getting us over
there so now we're looking at Iraq
that's right so yeah exactly
what had you done with your platoon
to before deployment did you do a normal
workup we did a very Hasty three-month
work up so I think we went out to NTC at
Fort Irwin we did a mini shooting
package uh we did a patrol package and
that was it so it was really Hasty and
how's this Force Recon so you're a
platoon Commander yep and how many guys
you got in your platoon about 30. okay
yeah so it's about the same size and
how's this platoon uh amazing but I you
know I entered this platoon now as I
think I had two marines who were younger
than me everyone else was more
experienced had a bunch of Tours under
the belt I was the the FNG for sure and
um very intimidated coming into this I
had now I had a you know the combat
deployment under my belt so I had a
little bit of uh experience but I also
hadn't gone through normally as a new
platoon Commander you're going through a
full shooting package of full weapons of
tactics package you're going through all
of this I had to a compressed piece of
that so that was a that was a hard
transition for me but I was really lucky
to have an exceptional platoon sergeant
and amazing team leaders
so when you get to Kuwait the the
invasion's imminent it is and we don't
know how long so we basically show up
and say hey hang out in Kuwait in this
Tent City and train and at some point
you know we think the invasion is coming
and I think it was maybe two months
something like that yeah if you got
there in February it must have been like
two months and so what was your mission
to asking when The Invasion happened so
we did
um we put some teams in really early in
the first couple days I think uh first
day we put a team up near
um I think north of alcut
um looking at so these were deeper
contestants The Marine Corps Force Recon
basically had you know kind of dual
Mission set they did the green side deep
reconnaissance mission and then there
was the direct action piece we did all
deep reconnaissance stuff so early on it
was looking at uh major highways keeping
an eye on major Iraqi units to get
advanced intelligence on things
um and then we did a similar Mission
um in uh al-hoa so we ended up in ahala
for a while file we spent a little bit
of time on the Iranian border basically
staring at Sand doing nothing
um so let's say Halla yep so you guys go
into Halal or you're out on the
outskirts of Hawaii we are right in we
are right next to the the uh ruins of
Babylon there like literally sitting
right on the river so are you guys
dunking are you hiding are you liking
that kind of we're in a relatively
secure area
um going out and doing
um kind of missions in and around that
space and you're reporting back what
you're seeing had the push already gone
past Hala at this point it had yeah okay
so you guys were like a stay behind
force that was gonna check things out
and see what the atmospherics are there
and and you know I think at that point
looking back I don't think we
necessarily had a really good clear
Mission like we were supposed to be
forces supposed to be a meth asset out
way out in front and uh we ended up
after those initial few days of the war
um I think with a little bit of a
question mission for the next month or
so how was the mentality like once the
war kicked off it was uh you know I
think excitement
um a little bit of candidly frustration
so we got into a couple places like
sitting up on the Iranian border sitting
in ahala where we were twiddling our
thumbs and felt feeling like gosh we
could we could be doing a lot more we
could be adding a lot more value a lot
of frustration from folks uh on the team
yeah I didn't know I didn't know that
you guys did
those like kind of straight
reconnaissance missions in the in that
War I didn't know that until you just
told me and that was just the that was
just the initial kind of roll up so you
know the the division moves so fast so
it wasn't a long period it was maybe a
week maybe
um and then we ended up where
um you know essentially behind ford
lines doing kind of local operations any
any significant thing happened there
that not really Leadership Lessons
Learned uh well definitely some lesson
learned we had
you know during that period are so I
came into force and I worked for my boss
was the company Commander which that
bill was in o5 Lieutenant Colonel and
the Marines uh had a great Lieutenant
Colonel when I came in checked in and
then he got replaced and the guy that we
deployed with our commanding officer
there was
challenging I'd say uh from a leadership
perspective
um very self and career oriented a lot
of decisions that were
transparently about him and his
advancement in his career some decisions
that put Marines lives at risk and so we
had this really really uh challenging
and fraught scenario where and all the
Marines could see it you know in the in
the general right in the in in force
continence we're dealing with more
season more experience they all see
what's happening
and it led to a very very tense very
challenging environment where you had a
lot of Marines uh get very very
frustrated at the leadership they were
seeing with you know a few of us sitting
in the middle and and trying to deal
with it
so I just wrote down we know and that's
just a message out there to everybody if
you're in a leadership position and
you're doing things that are for
yourself we know we know what you're
doing everyone sees it you no matter how
smart you think you are we know what
you're doing we see right through it you
can't fool us what did you do to try and
buffer this guy from your troops it was
I look back on it actually it was I mean
this is cliched but sure I think I
probably learned more from working for
that leader than I did from working for
the great leaders I think there were
some things I I tried to do to protect
our Marines so I I did my best to when I
was in front of them I didn't express my
frustration with him you know I
supported the mission I supported the
decisions that we were making even the
ones that I disagreed with so I didn't
want them to see me undermining
decisions that were being made we
already had enough challenges with
confidence in the chain of command at
the same time I he definitely influenced
my the way I showed up in a way that was
not as constructive it became I got to a
point where every day I was like
this guy whatever comes out of his mouth
I'm not it doesn't even matter if I
agree with him I'm gonna fight him on
everything and and you know we would sit
as peers you know in our tent at night
and just about this guy it did
nothing to help us it was so you know we
finally got to a moment where I think it
it finally hit home for me where I was
like Jesus I I get to choose how I show
up and I'm letting this guy affect the
type of leader I am my mentality my
mindset and uh you know I look back on
that as a one of probably the most
profound learnings I've had as a leader
like you can go through
circumstances you always have a choice
in how you show up yeah I get asked that
question probably 10 times a month you
know I've got this bad person I work for
in my my answer is always the answer
that people don't want to hear is like
like oh yeah you have a bad leader cool
build a good relationship with him this
is the best possible thing you can do if
the best possible thing you can do is
try and build a good relationship with
them so you have some kind of influence
over them because if you don't have a
good relationship with them you have no
influence whatsoever yeah so the best
thing you can do try and build a good
relationship with them and then you can
maybe sway swam in one directional or
another a little bit but just deciding
that oh this guy's an and so I'm
gonna be an you're just not
going to be
you're going to be in a worse spot
that's right essentially yeah and by the
way that you know that was I was
relatively young having the benefit now
of you know a couple decades you know in
your career this is going to happen to
you multiple times yeah guaranteed
military civilian business and I
remember someone saying to me once
um you know the the goal is being able
to look at every scenario and be proud
of how you showed up
no matter what the circumstances are do
you look back and feel good about how
you showed up as a leader yeah I always
tell people that you can go meet there's
leaders that I worked for that
I definitely
did not like very much and
that they never knew it you know like I
was just professional okay so that's
what we're doing yep sounds good let me
do let me see what I can make happen
here that's and again no one wants to
hear that because everyone thinks well
you know someone's taking care of
themselves you should stand up for them
cool it sounds cool it does it sounds
cool it sounds heroic even but then what
happens you get fired or you get dealt a
even worse hand and you didn't take care
of your guys you have less ability to
take care of your troops you have less
influence on the mission so it your ego
feels good it's an ego Victory but it's
it's essentially in the in the big
picture in the Strategic picture it's a
loser that's right I was very lucky so I
was a prime enlisted guy for eight years
so by the time I was an assistant
platoon Commander I was
28 years old or 27 years old which might
not seem like that big of a deal but
compared to 22 that's a big deal so I I
was lucky in that respect and I was
starting to learn these lessons so I was
a little bit a little bit I always feel
like I was just ahead of
just ahead of some of the stupidity I
would have pulled off three years prior
two years prior totally I look back I'm
like I'm glad I'm glad I was in that
position when I was you know 22 because
I would have been like you got to be
kidding me this guy's a piece of
you know what I just was like I said I
was just lucky enough to have been a
little bit older and be able to pull
that off so how long were you guys how
long do you guys stay we were there
through I think probably July of 03. so
I think I rotated back in July of 2003
and at that point you know so I'd been
with the unit for
a little over a year at that point and
was about would have gone into uh you
know working cycle so deploy again with
the MU probably go back overseas
Recon yes so I would have been able to
finish out my tour there and I decided
at that point
um I'm not working for this guy for
another year and a half and I spent a
lot of Cycles since thinking about that
decision and
um you know it was I for me that my
career in the Marine Corps was about
trying to create the opportunity where
maybe I could have shot at being that
platoon commander and you know walking
away from that was a hard decision but I
felt like it was the right thing for me
at the time
um and again lots of mixed feelings
looking back on it so what's your move
when when you decided to get out of the
Marine Corps so you know I had I decided
at that point hey I'll get out and you
know initial emotion is excitement uh
you know I uh get to think about what's
next not being a marine I've been on
active duty for 10 years don't have to
shave every day I can go more than a
week without getting a haircut everybody
exactly if I could do that I would do
that but uh and that was followed very
quickly by Terror of holy I have to
get a job and I don't even know where to
start and so I enjoyed a little bit of
the San Diego Summer and then I I
thought well maybe I'll just go to grad
school I don't know about business
I actually spent some time here in San
Diego interview there's a bunch of
military recruitment firms and I met
with some of them and nothing that I saw
there was interesting and I went through
this crisis of like oh what did I
just do they offer you it's like they
show you the entire menu and you're like
I'm not hungry oh dear God uh and uh
it's so I decided to go you know apply
to grad school so you know studied for
this test and applied and put my
application in and that would have been
this was summer of O3 so it was to start
in the fall level four so I basically
had a year what did you do for a year
moved to Colorado and ski bombed so did
you grow up skiing in New Jersey uh I
did
um yep so uh ski with my parents up in
the in the Northeast and had a wedding
in mind uh we would go to Killington
Pico uh Jay's Peak and just the whole
the whole gig the whole you know she
device here she device there you know
that for sure sharpen sharpen those
edges freeze your ass off
um and so yeah I figured hey I've got
some time when am I gonna have the
opportunity like this I was single uh
and so moved to Colorado with a buddy
who I served with and we had a great
time how long was your hair uh it got
pretty pretty long my hair does not look
good long I start getting these like
wings on the side it's pretty bad so uh
but it was awesome so we're in Colorado
uh so I got a worked at a bar at
Keystone and I was lucky my employer was
Vail Resorts so I had a you know with
that job I got a season pass to you know
four or five Resorts there and got a job
bartending which is hands down the best
job in a ski town you show up for work
at 3 P.M you work late you make decent
money in cash tips and you can ski every
single day so I skied 100 something days
that year uh and then ended up starting
grad school The Following fall
and this is up in Stanford correct yes
and and then how's this go down how's
this is you learning stuff is it cool so
I you know went through another like
similar moment of like you know you show
up uh this was for you know business
degree and show up and most of my
classmates are coming out of investment
Banks and consulting firms and I you
know know the lingo or raising their
hands in class they've seen it all
before I knew nothing and so like huge
crisis of confidence at this point of
like once again
how am I ever gonna find a job
um you know the way you know business
school setups you do your first year and
then you apply for an internship in the
fall of your first year for that
follow-on summer and then you come back
for your second year before you go work
full time and you know so I applied for
a bunch of jobs uh at Stanford they have
this system where you companies will
come on campus so let's say it's uh
Morgan Stanley comes on campus or Google
comes on campus and they say hey we're
gonna interview 20 people
you submit your resume if you're
interested they pick 10 of them and then
Stanford says you know we want to give
people who have non-traditional
backgrounds a shot so we're going to let
people bid on the other 10 spots so in
my two years there I can get picked for
a single interview
um so you know kind of reinforcing this
this isn't gonna work out but
fortunately it seems weird to me you
know there's a lot of I I'd say I was in
the very early wave of like Post 9 11
Veterans oh okay so you know today tons
of veterans who have done amazing things
in the valley but at this point there
were not that many and a lot of these
companies that are up and coming are
only a few years old so you know I
applied to Google in o5 and Google
hadn't been around that long so you're
dealing with we don't need some freaking
Marine here they're like we need this
Tech dude totally so you've got a
recruiter that's well intentioned has
respect for the military but looks at my
resume I was like I don't even I don't
even know how to what this means platoon
Commander we don't need it that's right
pretty sure we're not looking for that
exactly so um I got lucky at Google
because I I had submitted my resume
there was a Naval Academy guy who was
working there I reached out to him he
was kind enough to grab some time with
me and literally hand walk my resume to
a recruiter and help translate it what
was his job at Google he was working on
uh the team that supported advertisers
so he was managing kind of sales and
operations team that supported
advertising clients and so this is after
your first year at Stanford yeah you you
no one's none of these companies select
your resume Stanford gave some of these
companies your resume like hey can we
throw this throw this dude this knuckle
dragger right and and so one of them was
Google so Google actually came through
and outside so I applied to a bunch on
campus Google I had to work through this
veteran so I reached out to him and said
hey would you mind is there anything you
can do I think I had applied directly
didn't hear anything this is 2005
Google's growing like crazy and was
super disorganized so
um the only way I got my foot in the
door there was through this other vet
who was nice enough that led to an
on-campus interview uh I met with a guy
and went through the interview and and
things worked out and so this was for
your summer internship that's right okay
and then how's that summer internship it
was great I mean it was you know it's
funny I I
had not worked a single day in
technology you know my last job was
besides bartending I had experience you
know attending bar and and you know
logging an M4 around and so I show up on
Google's campus and Google's campus is
like for me it might as well be a
carnival like there are pool tables and
ping pong tables and it's this beautiful
spectacular and Incredibly intimidating
for me I remember I did my interview and
you know they had made me an offer for
the internship which I pretty you know
was pretty sure it was a mistake
um and I go to meet with the guy who I'm
going to be working for my host for the
summer and he's like look I what do you
want to work on I'm like I don't even
know what to say and he's like I got
seven projects let me just read them off
to you and you can choose so he reads
through all these projects I have no
idea what he's talking about like none
of them mean anything to me and the last
one he's like hey we're about to launch
this AdSense API and so we need someone
to work on that you know go to market
strategy for the AdSense API and I was
like that sounds amazing I'd love to
work on the AdSense API I don't know
what API I had to go look it up so I go
into that being like I'm gonna make a
complete ass of myself I know nothing
about technology I can't write a single
line of code my perception is you've got
like the smartest people in the valley
working there
and I remember I had this this amazing
uh professor at Stanford
um a guy named Irv grossback who teaches
a class on leadership there's
exceptional he built Cablevision huge
cable conglomerate uh and he basically
gave this advice he said look just
simplify things like be useful and be
liked over the summer just when it comes
down to that so I showed up and you know
I worked hard and learned over the
course of the summer that you know a lot
of the things that I had learned in the
Marine Corps a lot of things I'd learned
like turns out getting done working
hard holding a high bar being a great
teammate those things pay dividends in
this completely different and foreign
environment so left that summer had a
great time loved it learned a ton and
left with an opportunity to go back
there after my second year
so then it's another year at Stanford
what's your
schedule when you're at Stanford
Business School so business school and
law school are very different at Law
School you study a lot and learn stuff
business school the first year is is
like everyone comes in as like Gunners
ready to do a great job and then the
second year is very social so uh and
then the class bifurcates into the
people that like want to spend their
time on on the academics and my second
year I spent more time you know with
friends and classmates and we did some
volunteer stuff and so you know you had
a few hours of class every day did a lot
of training in sports so you had a lot
of former athletes so we'd get after it
together and then a lot of social stuff
as well like what what sports are you
doing at this point so we are playing a
ton of pickup basketball we're doing uh
we have this big actually pretty cool
they had this competition between West
Coast Business Schools where it was a
mix of Charity and Sport so you would
compete on raising money for Special
Olympics
um and then we would host all these
schools at Stanford and it was a weekend
of sports competitions uh and so you'd
play flag football and basketball and
softball and run a 5k and uh just get
after it we're not in the best of shape
so you have a lot of a lot of injuries
after that weekend
a lot of pulled hamstrings but uh it was
a good time
okay what do you what are you learning
I'd say mostly at you know in business
school you know I I tell folks now like
you don't come out of business school
with the next expertise to do any job in
business
what you get out of business school is
like broad exposure into Frameworks
Concepts ways to think about things so
what is marketing what is finance how do
you think about it so if you do a good
job I think you can come out and ask the
right questions but you certainly don't
come out with a level of expertise that
sets you up to be really great in any
particular role so for me I had zero
business vernacular zero coming out so I
learned a lot about that type of stuff
so then you graduate from there and now
it's Google Now it's Google yeah so I go
back and how's that it was great so I
went back to Google and I got a chance
to work on so I worked on what was
effectively kind of customer support and
sales and this is 2006. do they throw
you in charge of a team they do so that
was really important to me so I when I
came out of my first summer I worked a
little bit on uh in an area called
product management so at Google I would
say if there is an internal hierarchy of
influence product management is probably
at the top product yeah product product
management and Engineering at Google uh
rule so they're figuring out what the
strategy is what to build uh and then I
spent the other half of my time working
on operations or customer support on the
product management side
um uh really interesting you get to work
with the engineering team a lot more
influence I'd say was perceived within
the valley as a much more attractive
career path and certainly valued that
way internally uh for me I got to the
end of the summer had to choose do I
want to go to the product management
route or the operations route and most
people thought I was nuts to even think
about it like of course you go product
management
um and I decided to go operations
because in operations you had the chance
to lead a team and in product management
you didn't and someone had given me
really good advice around that and thank
God because I would have been I'd say a
mediocre at best product manager maybe
slightly better than average so product
manager means that we're building Google
Docs or we've got Google Docs and it
needs an upgrade on this and you're
going to kind of oversee that am I close
figuring out what's the strategy and
who's the customer and what their needs
so you're working with the engineering
team to help them understand what to
build and uh exactly and then what's the
job that you took instead uh what I
didn't said was answering emails from
pissed off users of the product
aggregating the top requests dealing you
know it managing it you know managing a
team of folks who are working directly
with your customers dealing with the
data day issues that come up as part of
it so customer support I always said
like for a long time I always worked on
teams that had the biggest like
self-esteem issues Within These
companies it was the teams that were
perceived as like our team our work
isn't as important as these other teams
and so that was a really good learning
for me early on how do I articulate what
we do in a way that really resonates
with these folks to keep them motivated
and excited and the leadership that you
learned in the Marine Corps
still works still works I mean I I had a
little bit of an adjustment phase some
of the some of the language of
vernacular had to change a little bit
but that was you know it seems so dumb
to say it but I learned that like you
know what human beings are human beings
right leadership there are so many of
the principles that are Universal and I
learned that there for sure so then how
long have you had that job for I was
there for only a little under two years
so I I was there for about two years
loved it learned a ton Google is a
really fun and exciting place to be at
that point and uh I was looking at
another role internally and a friend of
mine from grad school called me and said
hey he was working at Facebook at the
time called me and said hey we are
building a support team building an
operations team we're looking to hire
someone to build it you want to come
over and interview
and at this point I'm like dude I have
less than two years of experience
outside the Marine Corps and he's like
look you should just come over and
interview so this is 2008 so I went over
and interviewed interviewed with the you
know the executive team so you know with
with zoc and a bunch of the other senior
leaders at that point uh and got hired
into this role that I was totally
unqualified for it just incredibly lucky
that the person who hired me didn't
realize how underqualified I was because
he was a business development guy not an
operations guy you know and so I came
into this role
and uh you know at the time in
retrospect looks like an obvious shift
at the time people thought I was nuts to
leave Google this is the point when
Google's you know grown really fast so
you're being uh extremely humble here
obviously you know I didn't know what I
was doing and all this stuff but is it
that humility you think that is getting
you these positions because I know the
number one quality I tell people to look
for when they're hiring people is look
for someone that's humble because you
take someone that's smart enough they're
getting there if they're humble they'll
figure out what to do and they'll make
it happen would you say that's you know
instead of just blaming the guy that
hired you for not recognizing how dumb
you were giving yourself a little bit of
credit to say look you went in there and
when they asked you a question you
didn't know you said you know I'm not
really sure about that but I'm sure we
could get it figured out for sure and
and you know that's absolutely part of
it the other thing I'd say is I think my
um
I think coming from a different domain
was ended up being a huge Advantage for
me so the thing that I was most worried
about was I'm going to come in and
interview for a role where the
requirements are 10 to 15 years of
experience in consumer technology
leading teams I don't have that I've
worked for 18 months in Tech in total
and so the way I compensated for that
said look I can't manufacture experience
but what I can do is make sure I'm the
most well prepared interview ever so I
would read I read everything I read
their 10ks even though I didn't
understand them I used every product I
would support submit support requests
for all the products that use their
competitors I got to the point where if
I was where you did that for the
interview oh yeah I squared away right
there everyone I knew there was a little
more through this game right hey a
little bit more than luck well it's you
know it it would that's and that's where
I learned in the military like I will be
the most prepared and so I got in and I
remember my early interviews I was lucky
to get my early interviews out of the
way at Stanford and I was a train wreck
like thank God none of those are on
video
um but I got to the point where I my
mentality was if I get asked a question
that I do not have a prepared answer for
I've failed
and so I had a you know dozens and
dozens of pages I would write out all
the questions and I would think about I
knew I had the challenge of look I can't
just recite military experience because
people don't get it I have to help them
understand how my experience is relevant
in this totally different cultural
context so how do I think about the
stories I tell and the way that I tell
them that aligns with what they're
looking for so what is the culture here
okay great what's the misperception I've
got to overcome okay leadership in the
military is tops down hierarchical
misperception okay I know that that is
the perception this person is likely to
have how do I make sure whether they ask
me directly or not that that answer gets
into the conversation and dialogue so I
got to the point where I prepared you
know knowing that I didn't have domain
expertise I walked in just about and I
still do that now I think I my
aspiration when I interviewed for the
CrossFit job I'm going to be without
question the most prepared person they
talk to you know this is 20 years in to
my career and and so
um that was something I learned earlier
what year is this this is 2008 Facebook
so the economy already crashed at this
point it was uh just before so this is
February uh 2008.
um just before the economy crashes
um Microsoft had invested at Facebook
invest just invested in Facebook
Facebook is making a little bit of money
but is mostly bleeding money you know
the narrative at this point is everyone
told me social media isn't that you're
never going to make money you're an
idiot
why do you think you made that decision
I was
um I was still pretty young and I was uh
the same reason I went into the Marines
the same reason I wanted to go to force
like it was hard and new and I didn't
know if I could do it but I I was really
seeking like Risk seeking at that point
still I love the people I love the
culture and I thought this is going to
be an amazing experience how many people
were at Facebook at the time probably
about 350 400 somewhere in that range
and it was probably
maybe somewhere 30 40 million users
mostly college in the US still had just
launched internationally so it's still
pretty early when did Facebook like ramp
up completely
well it depends how you define that I
I'd say that over because I guess 30
million users is ramped up enough I mean
now it's now it's peanuts 30 million
users is nothing you don't get out of
bed for it in social media but I'd say
that like within the next year or two
things started to really turn and we
started to build the ad business started
to scale it we started putting the
infrastructure in place internationally
where folks are like oh okay this isn't
a novelty when I joined Facebook Myspace
was bigger
so Myspace was still winning at that
point so but within a year or two it
became pretty clear that Facebook was on
a really strong path got it so you get
there and what's your job while you're
there so I I show up my first week just
left Google and I'm supposed to come
into this job managing this online sales
team which is basically selling
medium-sized advertisers getting them to
buy Facebook ads so I show up on my
first day excited for the new job a
little anxious because I just left
Google after I feel like I've finally
figured things out and my buddy who had
introduced me there introduces me to
another guy and he says hey Don meet
so-and-so I said oh you know really nice
to meet you what do you do here and he
said well I managed a team that supports
medium-sized advertisers
and he says what are you gonna do and I
said uh I thought I was gonna do that
but there's got to be a good explanation
for this so I go back to my the guy who
hired me and I said hey I'm trying to be
diplomatic it's day two
um hey I talked so and so and and can
you help me understand your vision for
this role and he cut you know basically
says yeah we're basically going to do
this guy reported to one of his peers
they did not get along and he said we're
going to take all the most profitable
advertisers from that guy's team and
we're going to manage them now keep in
mind these two Executives my boss and
this other guy's boss both have a
revenue number they're responsible for
uh they don't like each other so my
second day I realized I have no job this
other guy's like off basically
three days later my boss pulls me in and
he's like hey how's your first week
going I'm like well a couple of bumps I
didn't anticipate but he's like yeah
well I'm leaving the company so by day
five I have no job and no boss and he's
like but uh look you're gonna report to
so and so it'll be great so I talked to
this other guy he said in the meantime
if you've got some time why don't you
see if you can walk up and down
University Avenue in Palo Alto and see
if you can get some of the restaurants
to buy Facebook ads
and so yeah I'm on my first place
exactly and I'm like holy and I
just left Google I have no job my boss
is leaving and uh you know so that next
week I showed up and I I remember there
was another inside sales team that they
were trying to hire someone for I'd
never done that and I just came in and
said I'm gonna start building this team
and I know I'm not qualified to do it
but when you hire someone will hand it
over and then you can figure out what to
do with me at that point so I brought
him my business school textbook on how
to build a sales team I'm sure everybody
was laughing at me and terrified and
started building the team and uh did
that for three or four months and then a
woman who I had worked for it at Google
came over became my new boss she
Consolidated a bunch of the operations
under me and you know things kind of
grew from there but it was a little bit
of a shaky first experience and then how
long how long were you at Facebook I was
there four years and then what did you
grow to like what was your senior
position and how many people were you in
charge of so I when I started there the
team was probably the initial team was
probably four or five and then took on
some other teams when I left team was
probably six seven hundred
and that's probably about 20 25 of the
company
um we had so you grew from five people
to what'd you say 60 700 somewhere in
that range probably yeah so we were
really fast so insane growth it's hard
to onboard 600 people when I was at
Google Google grew with a similar
capacity we had no constraints on hiring
they said basically if you can get
people through the process you can hire
as many people as you want which is kind
of insane to think about Facebook is a
similar rate of growth so we had to
figure out like how do you preserve
quality how do you put the right process
in place but I got a bunch you know I
was so lucky I got a chance to do so
many things there I got to open our
office in Dublin I got to open an office
in India we got to build new functions
from scratch got to deal with
governments uh again whole host of
things I not done before and Facebook
was really cool at that point because
the environment was just look we're
going to give you the space if you
demonstrate you can get stuff done you
can earn as much scope as you can take
on it was all about impact it was it was
very meritocratic and how things were
structured and that was really really
energizing for me and they went from 30
million users when you started what were
they up to and four years later
so what year is it when you leave so I
left in 2012.
and then what what brought about that
decision so I'd been there for four
years
um loved it so I went you know went from
a job where it was you know small team
very Hands-On a lot of early building to
um you know by 2012 had built out we had
an amazing team senior leaders
um a lot more of my job became
interfacing with other parts of the
organization and I felt like my personal
kind of learning curve had slowed down a
little bit so I was kind of ready for
the next thing at this point I knew I
knew what I was better at and I knew
what I was not good at and so for a
little bit they said I want to try
something in marketing did not go well
uh reinforced for me that was not the
right path and so I loved Facebook I
wanted to stick around hold on you're
good at Building Sales teams but you're
not good at marketing yeah different
skills on that so so on the marketing
side I said I think that the the skill
set around the storytelling creative
stuff the reason that you were an
engineer in college and not an English
exactly the same thing exactly right and
on the sales side a lot of uh a lot of
it was about team and team building and
structure and process those are the
things that I was more comfortable with
um so yeah I I was you know at this
point had talked to my boss and said hey
look I love it here I'm ready for
something new there wasn't a role that
really made sense for me and then had a
friend call me who was at Pinterest and
said hey
um you know it's this is 2012. Pinterest
had gone from hundreds of thousands to I
think north of 10 million users in like
four months insane growth and the team
was about 35 40 people and he said hey
you know we're building the team what do
you think so it similar to moving from
Google to Facebook
um you know thought to myself gosh this
is a great opportunity to go to another
fast growing company uh this friend of
mine and some of the other leaders were
some of my favorite people
um from Google and Facebook so felt like
the team was an amazing fit and it was a
role that had the opportunity for some
new learning for me so not only
operations which I had done some of the
sales stuff but managing now a senior
marketing leader so not doing the
marketing myself but hiring a a
marketing leader building outs early on
our human resources and people team and
so it was a chance for me to kind of
take that next step and learn a bunch
more
same thing you roll into the interview
just study hard for it be ready and now
you had a bunch of experience I had a
bunch of experience and and actually the
founder of Pinterest uh I had worked
with his wife uh she was my uh she
partnered with me on the human resources
team at Facebook so I knew her well she
was good people I knew the founder
um and so I had a little bit of a
relationship he knew me a little bit
through her
um and through some of the other uh
Executives who I had worked with before
you know um in these tech companies I
know I've gone up and worked with a
bunch of them and and you see like what
you were talking about earlier you know
they've got like the pool tables and
like the Lego room and like all these
things
but and there was a while ago I guess it
was as the work from home stuff and
people were kind of talking about that
there was some video that came out or
someone that worked at Twitter and they
were like lounging around all day but
what I when I was when I worked with
those companies like they're busting
their ass and the reason they have food
there is so they don't ever have to
leave and the reason they have like a
place to lay down is so they can lay
down for half an hour and then get back
to work what kind of hours are you and
your team putting in when you're at
Google and Facebook and then Pinterest
oh yeah particularly Facebook was an
incredibly intense environment so I was
and it was not a healthy period for me
uh so I was you know
five six days a week I'd I'd roll into
the office at 6am would skip the workout
eat like work till you know three
days a week I was there probably past
midnight back in at six a.m the next day
you've got people there till 2 3 A.M
grinding that was pretty common
um and when you're at home you were
working are you making a ton of
money at this point oh not not you know
at this point you have you know the
promise there was was the equity you
know so what the company would be worth
and you know that was there I'd say but
what was driving people was was the
excitement and the impact in the culture
and early on it was really you can do
this we can do this yeah we're gonna win
this thing yeah it was it was exciting
and uh and so that was that that culture
of people working hard and you're right
like I think the culturally the
Inception a lot of a lot of those things
was in service of how do we enable
people
to work their highest level of
productivity
fine line today 18 hours a day and I
think at a certain point companies get
big enough where they still have all
those uh amenities but they don't have
that you know same Drive anymore and
then you can see where it starts to
become like oh you're in the Lego room
again
like you've been in the Lego room for
two and a half hours what what's going
on yeah and and exactly and I think at
some point you know I think early on we
understood the intent behind them
everyone did like this isn't so you can
off for three hours a day this is
it look if you need to create some space
if you need to work it off because
you're grinding great we're gonna make
that available but the expectation is
you're going to be here and get after it
and I think at some point when you lose
the why and the intent behind it and
you've never heard it before you have
this really dangerous slippery slope
where now the expectation is wait how
dare you not serve me three meals a day
yeah and the wine bars the like multiple
like this corner over here is Asian food
this one's Italian food this one's
American food and this is going like 24
7. it's freaking kind of amazing it is
you see these things but then I remember
you know like you're going oh
there's a bar here these people aren't
even going to leave like they're gonna
have after work sit around and talk
about whatever project they're working
on and drink wine I see what's happening
here
exactly crafty yeah so the the Pinterest
thing which we discussed a little bit in
the beginning which I I'm not a huge I I
don't understand Pinterest that well but
what was the deal what's the deal of
Interest bro what brief me on it should
I be on Pinterest I think you're
probably safe not being honest okay just
the idea is
um is that it's a virtual pin board a
place to discover and save the things
that you're interested and passionate
about it Pinterest was really
interesting on a number of levels I
think it was almost the inverse of a lot
of the companies that took off in the
valley early on so if you look at the
Facebooks of the world and the Googles
they took off amongst mostly Tech dudes
on the coasts Pinterest resonated with
women you know Midwest south
um who were cultivating and crafting
these virtual pin boards saving things
that they love and so it was really
interesting for us early on so it's
basically it's a scrapbooking it's a
scrapbook right that's exactly right
it's a virtual scrapbook and kind of
Discovery things so so it's not a
surprise that I missed out on this gig
that you missed out on this thing and it
was really interesting for us over time
thinking about like how much do a put of
a push do we make in in getting men on
this or do we just double down because
it's working so extraordinarily well for
women so what where did that go what was
your job there so I was
um my title was head of operations which
was basically kind of the business
imagine the business teams so it was
when I first started you know wait was
this the COO or what's it kind of it
wasn't that entitled but it was a
similar scope in terms of role so how
many people were there when you show up
uh about 35 35 to 40 total in the
company
um I inherited a team of I think four
people and were you getting offers for
like knucklehead.com as well like how
did you select Google then you selected
Facebook then you selected Pinterest
like how come you didn't get a job at
freaking we'reabouttofail.com pets.com
yeah
um you know honestly a lot of it was a
lot you know probably luck and then some
I think coming out of Google I was
exposed being in an environment where
you start to soak in what matters and
you start to absorb some of the signal
around things yeah I was gonna say it
sounds like both both Facebook and
Pinterest had like a trajectory that was
visible they had an invisible trajectory
that you saw and you're like yo I and I
was on again really lucky like Google
the other thing too is is you know
looking back on this
really fortunate to get the job at
Google coming out of Google
Google is one of the only places that
had the type of scale in the valley that
these other companies were looking to
replicate so if you're at Facebook and
you're like okay we need to build a team
that can support hundreds of millions of
people all around the world and build an
operations team that combines technology
and people where do we find people who
do that oh let's go look at Google so I
you know I was lucky to be in that place
and then I got Google on Facebook and so
I get the luck of like a little bit of
the double whammy of it and and all the
lessons that come along with it and and
you know that that was a really
interesting place where you're at these
companies where the product you know in
the in the valley people will say
product Market fit like you build
something that like resonates and then
these software things can just take off
and I joined right after you know
probably a couple years after things had
taken off at Google a year or two after
things had taken off at Facebook the
year things had taken off at Pinterest
and that's a really fun time because
you've got the growth and you have to
build all of the you have to build the
team and the infrastructure to support
it and so yeah I was I was you know I
think a lot of it was having those
different experiences and then known
people and you rolled into basically
unconstrained Capital into all these
companies for the most part you know it
was yeah they were growing so fast uh
Google's I think probably already
profitable at that point and then
Facebook was growing so fast that they
could raise money yeah so you had
effectively unconstrained capital and
resources
um hire whoever you can yeah for a
period of Google that was the thing if
you can get them through the hiring
process you can hire them so then you're
also saying that at this time you're
working so much in some cases that
you're not working out you're kind of
like being lazy you're eating too many
freaking Donuts from the cafeteria the
whole nine yards for sure yeah they had
these really dangerous micro kitchens at
uh Facebook and Google I didn't know
what this is but we know it sounds good
are you salivating right now
but the yogurt covered pretzels were my
downfalls so I you know you know when
you get tired like my that whole cycle I
wasn't getting enough sleep I was eating
like uh and I remember at a moment
where I uh I was into Triathlon at this
point and I had done a race up in the
city in San Francisco and posted the
picture on Facebook and one of my
buddies you know you know your buddies
in the military are they show affection
by cutting you down yeah and so I posted
this picture and just Savage comment
from one of my buddies about my gut and
I remember reading that and be like I
need to get my together this is
embarrassing and so that was that I got
my act together a little bit at that
point and it and then are you are you
married at this point are you I'm not so
I met my wife
um so I'm dating at this point so my
wife I met my wife during my internship
at Google so she was she had uh gone to
school undergrad in the area she had
just started full-time at Google uh we
met during my internship uh and then we
dated uh during my time at Google we
both worked there I moved to Facebook
and then she moved over to Facebook two
years later so we worked together for a
while and then we got married married in
2010 so that was when I was at Facebook
okay so you are married now you're at
now you're at Pinterest yep she's still
at Facebook she's still a face at that
point at that time and at what point did
you get into CrossFit so I got into
CrossFit while I was at Pinterest okay
so so I had you know when I got out of
the Marines I had gotten into when I was
on active duty into Triathlon so played
rugby in college played a little bit
after college when I was on active duty
um got all jacked up blew out my
shoulder
um got into Triathlon did that for a
while and
um blew out a disc in my lower back so
this is you know I'm now at Pinterest
probably 35 36 my low back is jacked uh
I'm uh I'm running quite a bit and doing
the like you know Global gym Equinox
three days a week and you know a couple
times a year having like a some sort of
back episode where I am laid out on the
floor immobile bad and had a buddy of
mine who I used to run with in the city
say hey this is 2014. what do you think
about CrossFit and I had heard about it
I'd miss the wave on active duty so I
didn't see it then
um I didn't know a lot about it and my
initial reaction was I I can't do that
with my back like there's no way I can
do that you look at the website it was
like kettlebell swings and deadlifts and
you're like 7 000 kettlebell swings
um yeah so I you know it my initial
response was hey sounds awesome but no
and then he was persistent I said okay
like let's go give this a shot I'll give
it a try so he and I signed up went to
uh uh box in San Francisco about a mile
from uh Pinterest
dropped in and you know I would have
said walking in that I was in good shape
I was running 50 60 miles a week could
run pretty fast I was doing a marathon
about every year lifting quite a bit and
just got absolutely smoked do you
remember what the workout was I don't I
wish I'd written it down but I do
remember for the first probably two to
three weeks I came in last in every
workout I remember looking around and
like you know men women in their 50s are
destroying me and it's you know my
friend and I had you know at that point
I was sore as hell I could only do like
two days a week but I was completely
hooked uh that did it for me so I did
that for you know about a little over a
year in San Francisco and then when I
left Pinterest to go to my next job
uh founded a gym down in Palo Alto and
then what was the next job so I left uh
left Pinterest and went to a a really
small early stage company called Athos
so uh I had worked with a guy at
Facebook who left Facebook to invest
um and he had invested in this company
called Athos which made Compression
Apparel with embedded sensors that track
muscle activity so really interesting
technology it captured the electrical
signal at the major muscle level so you
could look for an athlete as you trained
which muscles were firing how hard are
they working when you looked at that
kind of data you could look at overall
movement patterns you could look at
overall load on the body so you could
see patterns that were predictive of
injuries so for me it was kind of the
intersection of two things I was super
interested in the sports fitness human
performance technology
and I had you know been at now three
companies that had taken off and I
wanted to try something earlier stage
and I remember meeting with this so I I
met with this investor and I'd known him
pretty well from Facebook
and I talked to a bunch of other
companies
and came down to uh Athos and Airbnb and
um I had gotten to know the founder at
Airbnb amazing spend much time there
incredibly impressed great company great
culture the job was very similar would
have been somewhat similar to what I had
done so another fast-growing company
doing operations and I met with this
investor and he knew me well enough he's
like
yeah it interesting or maybe it's
interesting but you've done a version of
that job you know you can do it this
other job you've never done this
you don't know if you can do it I don't
think you can do it
and that was it I walked out I was like
you I'm taking this job and uh so
for me it was like doing something early
stage that was high risk of failure
totally different environment was it was
Airbnb that early stage at this time as
well it was already kind of they weren't
the trajectory they were pretty big yeah
trajectory they were well past product
Market fit really strong growth great
Brands still a ton of opportunity yeah
you just figured I don't want to jump on
this another incredibly uh beneficial
rocket ship again
okay would you put it that way it makes
you sound like a complete I
wanted I wanted a new experience you
know like I was it was amazing and that
was really hard because that how many
people were at Athos at the time
probably 50 50 55 and
um you know two Founders two young
Founders
um two guys out of Waterloo in Canada
amazing guys great culture
and yeah so I you know I started there
and you know I figured hey this is as
close for me in terms of what we're
building this is as close to a 10 as it
gets sports fitness human performance
technology we were doing some work with
DOD doing some work with Pro Sport
really really interesting and it was an
opportunity to kind of learn this new
stage so this is like early in the
wearables very early and exactly the
higher capability wearables that's
because this is tracking so this is you
know when maybe when fitbit's at its
peak so it was hey you got gen 1
wearables which was in my mind was okay
there's a ton of demand here but also
hey gen one is Gen one there's an
opportunity to build something that's a
lot more sophisticated than just
movement and so Athos was this we had
this really interesting data set like we
could see what people's muscles were
doing so I thought in that there was a
lot of potential
um and working in a space that was
really fun and then what what happens
with Athos so I you know I um started
there as CEO and and about 10 months in
so founder amazing the two Founders
incredible one of them was CEO both
amazing entrepreneurs amazing human
beings about 10 months in founder and I
switch role so he moves into a more
technology focused role what he loves
what he's world class at I moved into
the CEO role first time for me being a
CEO
and then you know six years of battling
the startup grind and so
um you know if there's a mistake to make
early stage we made it I made it
um very humbling like well it turns out
it's not as easy as Facebook and Google
and Pinterest make it look doing this
is really hard lots of cultural
stuff that was hard you know being on
the being on the cusp of running out of
money constantly uh keeping people
motivated focused uh so it was it was
you know I say Athos was for me by far
the least successful in terms of the
outcome but you know in my my time in
technology my favorite experience and
the the experience I learned the most
from as a leader without question yeah
so you had some survivor's bias going
into it being that you'd just been a
part of companies that were just rocket
ships and then you jump into this
company and it was six years you were
there I was there six years where is it
at right now it based basically sold
part of the team and wound it down so we
didn't make it yeah and that's normal
that's just 90 plus the startups and I
knew that going in right
the the I was up at MIT and doing some
work with them and just the way that
whole system works it's sort of like um
so the same things happens with book
publishers so book publishers they buy a
hundred books they give a hundred people
100 Grand to write a book and none of
them sell well let me rephrase that
three of them sell yeah and that's where
they make all their money and the the
folks up at MIT when they talk about all
the money that they're putting starting
up all these same thing they're gonna
they're gonna put money into a hundred
different businesses three of them if
we're gonna make it and they're gonna
make all their money back and a lot more
Yep so very similar math yeah so so you
end up so what happens at the end of
this so we we got to a point where you
know I'd say we were let's call it a
year out uh our our Focus was we were
selling a bit into kind of pro and
college sport and so our uh use case
basically was injury prevention so we
could see if you're a you know wide
receiver on a college football team we
could see a hamstring imbalance present
before anyone could see it and then we
get help with protocols that would
mitigate and reduce injury risk
great for college and pro sports but
college and pro sports is a shitty
business small markets very hard and
costly to sell into so it's great from a
brand perspective and then we were doing
work with DOD actually so you know we
looked and said you know musculoskeletal
injuries and DOD are catastrophic in
number and cost most of them are
repetitive stress they can be mitigated
and so we were doing a bunch of work
there we had some early contracts with
the Air Force with appsock down at
lachlan's with some really good outcomes
but unfortunately just couldn't get to
kind of cross the chasm and get to Big
contract so then when did the CrossFit
opportunity present so I left that you
know we made the decision you know we
essentially said hey we're going to wind
the company down look for a buyer we did
that
um you know wound it down and then I
spent a little bit of time
um you know with family and then had a
friend of mine uh call me and say Hey
you know I heard crossfit's looking for
a CEO do you have any interest so he had
talked to the recruiters this is
probably
April of last year so a little over a
year ago and I said absolutely I would
love to be considered for it I knew I
was a really non-traditional I had not
worked in any sort of you know Fitness
or franchise per se or it's in
technology but I'd been in the community
for a long time
um and so he connected me with the board
and the executive recruiters I went
through the process
you know had this very funny experience
of my wife and I had had planned to be
off so we planned a three-week trip to
Central America and went through the
final stages the interviews doing
interviews over Zoom from Nicaragua
praying that the power wouldn't go out
um and that culminated you know that
wrapped up right before the CrossFit
games last year when you were studying
for the CrossFit CEO role what was your
what did it say on your flash cards on
your studying flashcards what were you
looking at what were you trying to
understand about the company so I you
know I wanted to understand a few things
I I wanted to understand
um just the overall state of the
community so you know how was the
average affiliate owner feeling how's
the average coach feeling how's the
average member is it growing did you
reach out to affiliate members and
members and coaches at this time and
what were they telling you I did so I
you know I reached out to you so I I had
trained for when I moved from uh
Pinterest onto Athos I started training
at uh NorCal CrossFit in Redwood City so
jazz gym NC fit now and so I had met
Jason a couple times and so I sent him a
note and said you know essentially would
you be willing to share some advice and
feedback can I pick it right so I talked
to Jason uh talk to a bunch of other
folks um I'd gotten to know uh Dave
Castro so I met Dave uh through another
friends
um and so I reached out to Dave and and
he was kind enough to kind of share his
perspective uh and so I wanted to get a
sense for you know where's the business
where the state of things where's the
team and where's the culture where's the
state of the community in the ecosystem
and then I wanted to get a little bit of
a sense for I also wanted to understand
the the ownership and you know who these
investors were what their priorities
were and then I tried to use that you
know to to come in with a point of view
on okay here's my albeit with limited
context here's my perspective on on
strengths weaknesses opportunities what
does that look like uh you know going
into the conversation
because it was trouble
at the time I mean when so so what
happened was
let's see uh coach Glassman who is the
founder and I think 100 owner of
CrossFit I think so he had like tweeted
a bunch of well he tweeted some things
he got had to step down like it was
around George Floyd it was just kind of
crazy
um he pulled all their social media like
off Social Media stuff like this and
again I'm not getting it all all right
because I
didn't track it that closely but you
know you'd see this stuff happening I've
had a CrossFit affiliate since 2007 or
2008 so I have to know a little bit
about what's going on but
so so that's happening you had
a bunch of the Affiliates were like oh
crossfit's gone crazy or whatever we're
out so you had that happening there's I
wouldn't say there's well there's
there's always been some level of
negative press around CrossFit with
people getting injured with people
getting rap dough with people being
with people being elitists like
these kind of things so you you have
those things which I think were
all these things were sort of uh maybe
things to consider for you right give me
a moment of pause yeah things to
consider and yet here's the here's the
thing that I would I would assume you
latched on to
which is the same reason why I still
have a CrossFit affiliate you have
something that is very very strong at
its core unifies people it definitely if
when when done properly it turns people
that are in terrible shape into great
shape it brings them together it makes
them stronger mentally physically it it
just has a has had a huge impact and
very much like jiu jitsu you ever turn
Jiu Jitsu uh not seriously okay well if
it wasn't for the Gracie family like you
can Gracie has the same you can say the
same thing about the Gracies right
people can say oh you get hurt people
can say oh it's cultish people can say
that they didn't uh evolve their beliefs
like there's a bunch of negative things
you can say about the Gracie family and
about the about Gracie Jiu Jitsu
that being said if it wasn't for Gracie
Jiu Jitsu
like well first of all Grace you also it
is an incredible like amazing I know all
the people from The Gracie family
they're all good people so there's that
but also if it wasn't for Gracie Jutsu
the UFC wouldn't exist and the UFC has
now gotten all kinds of people into all
kinds of martial arts and there's that's
undeniable no one can deny that fact so
for me it's a very similar thing you
have some for lack of a better word
drama around this element but at the
same time the element itself is so
powerful and so good that it just helps
a bunch of people so everyone should you
know you in California I mean in San
Diego you can there's Jiu Jitsu schools
on every corner uh and and not only that
you can go anywhere in the country now
and there's a jiu jitsu score people
email me from wherever East wherever
and that you know is there is there is
there is there a cross is there a jiu
jitsu School in wherever Idaho and I'm
like Google it yep there's one so
they're everywhere so that's because Jiu
Jitsu is awesome yeah and I can tell you
right now like people that talk about uh
Olympic weightlifting
guess what brought Olympic weightlifting
into the Limelight for it's it's
CrossFit power lifting same thing
gymnastics same thing these were these
were and and look I've been do you know
what Milo magazine is no okay Milo
magazines like a strong man Olympic
lifting magazine I've been a subscriber
that doesn't exist anymore but I was a
subscriber to that since 1994. I was
into this stuff but I'm telling you
right this stuff has been a niche market
around the world you couldn't go into a
freaking gym in 1997 and find an Olympic
lifting platform zero I never went into
a gym Echo Charles back me up uh no not
a public type no not a public type gym
like not a 24-hour fitness not a normal
gym that you could go into and pay a fee
there was no pull-up bars in many cases
there might have been one of those like
weird like curvy pull-up bars yeah you
know that I know that I'm against yeah
on a universal whatever but there was no
squat rack with pull-up bars that didn't
was no dip bar attachment to it these
things didn't exist there were certainly
no rings hanging from the ceiling
so
you had this thing that had issues but
damn if it didn't have if it hadn't had
a major impact and a lot of people had
been hugely beneficial so is that kind
of what you were weighing out in your
head for sure yeah and I you know I
think you framed that really well and
it's funny when I talk to people you
know people who love CrossFit they they
would say to me that more than one
person saying that sounds amazing you
should definitely not take that job it's
impossible
um you know with all of the love for the
community because they saw both sides of
the coin for me
you know I personally had had you know
this uh
really life-changing impact you know I
was when my back was jacked I thought I
was done getting after in the way that I
used to I was 35 being like all right
for the rest of my life
every morning when I wake up it's gonna
take me 20 minutes to be able to stand
up straight that is just like the price
I pay for being dumb when I was in my
20s and so you know for me totally
transformative
um you know not to mention meeting this
amazing community of folks now who I've
known for 10 years that I train with
every day who are you know good friends
and I saw the same thing happen for you
know hundreds of other people and so for
me yeah there was there were all of
those challenges
um you know all of the things that I
knew was going to make the job really
hard but I had never seen or experienced
anything that had the type of impact on
people's lives that CrossFit does never
and I you know I was lucky to work at
companies that have billions of people
using their product not one of those
companies has even closer the type of
impact than the last year for me just
reinforcing it like my my wife is kind
of sick of like me going home and like
let me tell you another story I dropped
into a random affiliate today you will
not believe this and so for me I looked
at that and thought gosh
it's already had a huge impact on so
many people's lives and it's just the
tip of the iceberg like we we have all
of these challenges but those are also
opportunities if we can we know it's not
as dangerous as people it's not
dangerous when done well
um we know it's not just for young super
fit people we know if you walk into an
affiliate you're going to see young old
folks who are fit folks who are just
starting in their Journey if we can just
help people understand that and start to
shift those perceptions holy cow like we
can magnify the impact of this thing
even more so
when I look at sort of the
the the past CrossFit okay it seems to
me like some of the problems of it were
you had uh Greg Glassman who was he's
like an ultra kind of libertarian type
of guy right like hey the the the the
the best will rise to the top and if
you're not good you'll just fail so
it seemed to me like that attitude look
I'm I'm pretty much a I feel that way
about most things too it's like hey if
you work hard and you do a good job
you're gonna Excel and you're gonna get
credit and things are gonna go well for
you
and
but it seemed like
so if you were a person that wanted to
open a gym and you were a badass person
and you cared about your clients and you
learned good technique and you maybe had
some background in Olympic lifting or
you get some background in in gymnastics
you had some background and some sport
that you became a good coach and you
would open your affiliate somewhere and
you would transform people's lives and
they'd invite their friends and also
they'd have an awesome gym and doing
great making a bunch of money and
changing people's lives
and then you got someone else that's
like maybe didn't do any sports maybe
isn't the best person maybe he's not the
best coach and yet they could kind of go
through the certification become a coach
and you know maybe they got a big ego
right and they want to compete or they
want to yell at people or they want to
force people to do things that they
shouldn't be doing and all of a sudden
you have someone get hurt right which
certainly if you do stupid things with
heavy weights you can get hurt
and I from my perspective because again
it's like the same thing we just talked
about because CrossFit was so strong
even some of those
coaches that shouldn't have been there
we're still able to bring people in
because you know people saw an article
about CrossFit and a person you know
they went on vacation and someone said
oh how'd you get in shape oh I do
CrossFit and they go back to their
Hometown I want to do CrossFit too and
they roll into this gym and it's not the
best coach and they're not getting the
right destruction and so things turn bad
so
when we talk about like the dangers of
CrossFit which you just which you just
said is if you do it right
you'll be okay like you can do a clean
and jerk with a PVC pipe and you should
when you start doing cleaning jerks so
now that now that we're in current days
what are we doing to address these types
of issues and sort of standardize and
professionalize the force yeah so uh
Bunch there I think the first thing I'd
say is I think it's we have to you know
make sure that we
recognize I think part of Greg's genius
early on was understanding that that
initial model was essential in
attracting the type of entrepreneurial
independent small business owners that
may CrossFit what it is today and so a
model in which we say hey look we're
going to give you the power to run your
own business and exercise your
creativity and build something that
works for your community I think was
really really important uh it also you
know without a a model like that we
wouldn't have 13 000 gyms today there's
no way and so I think for us moving
forward we have to be thoughtful about
making sure we Preserve the the autonomy
and the flexibility that allows our
affiliate owners to do what they do best
it's what you and I learned in the
military it's decentralized
decentralized command and and so that
that is it is you know if you look at a
traditional franchise business you you
uh you exercise quality by control by a
very directive leadership you will do
actually you will do I here's the 742
page document that's going to explain
exactly how everything's set and we're
going to come in and check every single
box that that will not work for us so we
have to do you know what we what we
learned to do in the military which is
now we have to be really clear about the
standard okay what is the standard and
you know uh Greg was right like
excellence in virtuosity that should be
our standard excellence in coaching
excellence in how we run our Affiliates
excellent so that you don't have to
think twice you can walk into any one of
our 13 000 Affiliates and you're gonna
have a great experience now that doesn't
mean they're all going to look the same
they won't they shouldn't part of the
beauty is there's something unique about
everyone but what should be consistent
is the quality of the coaching
um uh what should be consistent is how
you're supported and treated the
investment in the community the things
that we know really fundamentally matter
so the challenge for us is figuring out
how do we think about you know we have
to clearly articulate what the standard
is and we have to figure out how to
create the right incentives in the
community that allow people that reward
the folks Who deliver on that
and then in some cases for folks who are
not it's our responsibility we have to
be a custodian HQ we have to be a
custodian for the brand because every
every affiliate owner who is doing their
part who is holding the line is counting
on us because we know if you walk into
If somebody walks into an affiliate
who's not doing a great job it doesn't
just hurt that affiliate and that
individual it hurts every single other
affiliate and so they got to hold us
accountable we got to do a great job of
holding the overall community of coaches
and Affiliates accountable for
delivering that exceptional experience
and then as part of that we got to make
sure they have the resources to do it
and so this is has been a big shift for
us early on CrossFit was really a hey
send a sex amount each year license the
brand
it's on you over the last year and a
half or so we've invested a lot in a
team and in resources that give owners
tools and and things that they can use
to up level their coaching to build a
great business to learn how to support
customers through onboarding and all the
things that we know to be important yeah
it's um like the restaurant business
if you're going to open a restaurant or
you're gonna open a bar let's say
you gotta be personally invested in that
bar you got to be in there and like hey
what's up Fred yeah you're having your
use you got it but you gotta build that
thing yeah and it's that's what that's
what like you know at my gym that's what
I realized almost as soon as we opened
up I was like oh this is all about these
relationships with all these people that
are inside this gym and you can get to a
point where the people in the gym have a
relationship with each other and that's
awesome too but yeah you gotta get
people that are gonna set things up so
the way they like them which is the way
other people coming into the gym like
them they kind of like really care about
it and just like the best restaurants in
the world aren't
franchises it's not it's not like
Chili's right I mean nothing against
Chili's because that used to be like
kind of the go-to restaurant back in the
day but no one that's not on the list
you know of top restaurants in the world
even though it follows a perfect
protocol there's a franchise they get
they all get the same food comes from
the same place you know what you're
gonna get but that's not the best
restaurant it's not that it's not the
best restaurant in San Diego it's not
the best restaurant in Chicago there's
Chilis in it everywhere but those aren't
and they're fine but they're not the
best so if you want to go up a little
bit higher you got to give those people
the people that are there the people
that own it you got to give them the
autonomy to make things happen with
decentralized command yeah couldn't
agree more they've they've got a they've
got to feel true ownership
what was it like when you took over I
mean what what what go ahead I was
laughing because it uh my first week was
the week of the CrossFit game so it was
insane it was awesome but it was
six days of I think I've met two
thousand people in four days
um it was phenomenal
um very humbling
uh I learned a ton you know and so I
felt I was very lucky even though it was
a crazy first week
I got six months worth of learning
compressed into six days what are people
telling you
um you know
I I think by and large the top points of
feedback were from inside and outside
the company hey we love CrossFit we love
this community we want it to be
successful
um we need to understand where we're
going so we can line around it and so we
need Clarity of vision
um two we need consistency you know the
prior X years had been a ton of ups and
downs and for a lot of owners the
changes that we were going through at HQ
impacted them like it it we cannot be a
liability for them our job is to support
them and so they ask hey look we need
stability we need confidence in in where
HQ is going where the Brand's going
um from the team I'd say the team was
pretty banged up you know and I think
that the team was candidly probably you
know let's say maybe cautiously
skeptical hey we've had a bunch of
leadership changes
um you know we've gone from Greg this
Visionary founder who created this thing
that has impacted so many people that
that now foundationally is a part of
people's identity you're now the next
new guy
there's been a bunch of turnover what's
coming how many weeks are you going to
be here for yeah and oh by the way we
know this is a job that is really hard
to come into and be successful in and uh
so people were incredibly supportive
people were really candid with me so I
you know I walked out of that first week
with
a lot of excitement but I'd also say you
know reasonably grounded in the areas
where we had a lot of work to do what uh
what did you get told that made your
fears increase
um
we as a at HQ were we have we at that
point continue have extraordinary people
like the
rivaling the Marine Corps and people's
intrinsic connection to the mission and
the cause just unbelievably selfless
extraordinarily talented people we were
a shitty team
the company was incredibly siled so we
have you know roughly these we have our
affiliate business we have a business
around Sport and Partnerships and then
we have our education
those teams didn't really talk to each
other didn't really work together
um I'd say we didn't have a
a culture internally that was grounded
in high trust and Clarity and so you
know we were
not partnering well we were not showing
up we were speaking to the same
customers from different parts of the
organization in ways that weren't
coordinated
um we were stepping on each other there
would be uh you know well-intentioned
mistakes that blossomed into issues
because there wasn't a foundation of
trust internally that really brought it
all together and what I heard from folks
is hey that the the higher you get in
the organization the worse it gets
um so and I had spent enough time with
the leadership team that knew that we
had great people but we had some real
cultural challenges
and then the positive thing was everyone
freaking loved CrossFit they were
everybody exactly exactly how did you go
about crafting so you hear from these
from the team like we don't even know
where we're going how did you go about
crafting that what does that look like
so I spent the first couple months just
trying to get out and talk to as many
people so I thought about okay and you
spent a lot of time with our team and
get to know and hear from them we've got
so much Collective knowledge and wisdom
internally spent a lot of time with
owners affiliate owners spend time with
coaches and then talk to Partners as
well and then also you know we have a
bunch of folks kind of endemic press
within the CrossFit ecosystem so anybody
who was willing to talk to me I tried to
just pick folks's brain and then you
know I got out on the road so I went to
South America went to Australia wanted
to make sure I got the international
piece as well
um that for me as I had those
conversations you know themes started to
emerge okay here are the things that you
know people are saying that are great we
want to make sure we preserve to hear
some of the challenges
and you know I kind of put that together
into we sat down as a leadership team
and said okay our our job is to serve
and support the organization we owe them
Clarity and so that Clarity needs to be
supported first we need a long-term
Vision so we are very short-term
oriented right now people don't
understand what success looks and worse
actually their worst fears are now that
Greg has sold the company and we have a
new investor all they care about is
money and we're going to ruin everything
that made this special so we need to
communicate a vision to them that they
can get excited and uh and rally around
so we laid that out and we said okay on
top of that then that let's call that it
was 2023 so I said let's round it off to
2030. let's say a seven seven year
exciting Vision we're gonna do that work
then we're gonna do a work at three to
five year strategy so that the vision
helps us understand what it looks like
then we need to do the hard work of
figuring out how we get there and then
ultimately we're going to enter by the
end of the year we're gonna have a plan
that has a clear set of outcomes and
goals for next year that ladder up to
our three to five year plan and Ladder
up to our vision that we can communicate
inside the company and we're going to
share outside the company as well and
ultimately that'll be aligned against a
set of very objective goals so we can
measure our progress against and so
where are you at with that right now so
we did that work in the fall so we
started as a team and you know I
um you know the way we approach it you
know not right or wrong I I'll start and
write a you know I write a write it down
on paper I'll write a doc so I think I
wrote a I don't know five to six seven
page here's a vision Doc and since it's
a leadership team and said look most of
this is probably wrong or really off but
it's a starting point so I'm going to
try to outline my thinking and the
rationale for it a bunch of my
assumptions will be wrong help me inform
it so we spent a lot of that time as a
team got to a place where the team felt
really good about it we went then and
shared with the company and said okay
great and then we shared it externally
so we went to our affiliate owners and
in January uh right in Pleasanton up in
the Bay Area went to affiliate owners
and said hey here's our vision here's
what we're focused on here's what you
can expect from us we're accountable to
you we're going to be working on your
behalf
um here's what you can expect from us in
the short medium and long run
um and then you know that set up for us
allowed us to enter this year with a set
of goals that we said so we do it like
roughly six months we'll look and say
Hey you know by mid-year we want to be
here we'll take a minute and do
effectively an after action so we'll
look and say okay what went well what
went wrong what were the assumptions we
had coming in and then how do we make
sure that we learn from those to adjust
our strategy so we just went through
that process for the second half of the
year and we communicated that back out
to our affiliate owners up in Portland a
couple weeks ago and how's the reception
it's been good it's been really positive
I think generally
I'd say
um you know we've communicated that our
at the end of the day like what drives
everything we do is is reaching more
people and changing more lives through
CrossFit so it's not about Revenue it's
not about profit it's how do we take
this thing that is pretty amazing and
reach more people with it and oh by the
way if we do that this should be a great
business but but for us
um the financials are not the outcome
and then we talked about okay great what
that means is if we're going to get
there if we're going to reach more
people we had a bunch of problems we
need to solve so we got to address this
issue on how the brand is perceived that
it's dangerous that it's intimidating
that it's only for folks who are already
fit okay great we've got a strategy
we're going to work and what's that
strategy look like just generally
speaking Yeah so it's it's a mix of I'd
say kind of two high-level things one
it's um doing a bunch of work on the
storytelling side to elevate stories
that start to shift that perception so I
think the good news for us is we don't
have to change CrossFit
to come up with something that works for
folks who are older like we already know
it's already been there forever it's
been there forever all we have to do is
Elevate the stories that are happening
and do a better job of that so we got
some work to do on that front so a lot
of it is just storytelling and this is
an area our team has been really good
for some time the other side of it is we
got what we're not great at historically
is measuring the efficacy of our
storytelling so okay great we just
shipped X pieces of content which of
them are working so we can double down
on those that are working and those that
aren't we have a lot of like gut feel so
we need to know actually which of those
is driving traffic how is that traffic
converting we we should be accountable
to our owners around it it's funny how
wrong your gut can be oh my gosh and and
people will say with a thousand percent
conviction I know this is right yeah
watch this video this thing's going
viral no you got nine views and three
down votes
right but you you get that feeling like
oh this this is it this is a great story
especially with something like CrossFit
which people are so viscerally connected
to oh and so that's one of the areas
around our culture that we're trying to
shift a little bit the passion is
essential but we got to be rigorous we
gotta validate our assumptions so we're
doing better storytelling getting the
word out there what else better
measurements and then better one of the
things we don't do a great job of now is
if you get to our website
um we do a shitty job of handing you off
to an affiliate so our job should be for
folks who are sitting at home Peak their
interest in CrossFit get them to
crossfit.com and then hand them to a
local affiliate where they can start
their journey and right now the The
Experience on the website for us is is
not as tight uh as it needs to be so
we're working on that so you can have a
map like a Geo locator put your ZIP code
in here yeah so we've had we've had a
map for some time we're about to come
out with in the next couple of weeks an
update to the map which has been
overhauled so it's much better designed
and most importantly what it'll allow us
to start to do is actually measure the
number of people that we're handing off
to Affiliates so at the end of the day
we need to be able to understand for the
amount of cycles that we're spending on
telling the story how many people do we
hand off and how many of those people
become new members at a CrossFit
affiliate and so making sure we've got a
really well designed you know we'll call
it a marketing funnel that allows us to
see exactly how we're doing that work so
we can hold ourselves accountable and we
can communicate to Affiliates hey you're
you're spending money with us every year
we're putting that money to good use
here's how many people we are sending on
your behalf yeah
a few years ago at this gym
we all of a sudden we just like our our
whatever new inquiries of people walking
in and saying hey you know I want to
train it just went down a lot and we
spent like two months
and my business partner is like yeah I
don't know what's going on like we're
we're not just not knowing what's
happening and sure enough we'd somehow
fallen off of Google Maps right Google
Maps didn't have our gym anymore and all
of a sudden like we didn't even know
what happened and so that's when we
started paying attention to all this
kind of stuff but there's that's the way
it works right I mean you've got to get
you've got to be able to get people to
nowhere to go that's right we I thought
about that doing that a long time ago I
should have we should have Echo Charles
because people would always say where
should I change where should I change
Jiu Jitsu and it it doesn't matter as
much anymore that's why I haven't made
an effort to do it anymore because now
Jiu Jitsu is so popular and there's so
many people and people that aren't good
coaches they don't survive they the
internet will eat them alive like you
can't be a fake Jujitsu black belt and
be teaching because you'll just get
annihilated so but for a while maybe
like five years ago I was thinking we
should do sort of like a you know Jocko
approved this is an approved Jiu Jitsu
approved place to train and have a map
and you put in your zip code and there
you go these these are some cool
instructors here's the vibe there and
because it's so important people get
that interest they do the Google search
and yet the next step that's a big Next
Step you know I sell stuff online that's
a smaller step to click totally cart or
whatever yep but you're losing people at
each stage yep yep yeah and we you we
haven't you know for the past at least
few years have been doing a lot of the
the basic blocking and tackling so uh
you search for CrossFit on Google and
our competitors have the first row of
paid ads and that's a not an
untraditional thing but we weren't even
playing there yeah so we weren't even
making it hard for them so there's a lot
a lot of stuff that we're doing now
there that'll have a big impact yeah
that's like when people have the actual
name Jocko they'll buy my name on Amazon
or on Google and we we're pretty good
about it now we've we've made it cost
them a lot of money if they want to play
that game but uh you know it's pretty
insane that that's what goes down yeah
that you can you can bid on those
keywords on somebody else's trademark it
sucks yeah yep that's how these that's
how your old stomping grounds make money
right right
[Music]
trust me I was very far from any
important decisions like that
and so then what does it look like uh so
we got the um
the CrossFit Games coming up yeah what
in a week yes yeah starts next week are
you going yeah because I'm going for
sure it's sweet I I unfortunately I
didn't get it scheduled early enough so
I'm there for like a day but okay we got
the bunch of people coming up from Jocko
fuel to check it out I have only watched
CrossFit games on TV how hype is it live
it's amazing it's super awesome I uh
last year was my first games
um which I immediately regretted not
having gone before the watching the
competition is amazing but just being in
in and around the community so CrossFit
like I I but a huge part of crossfits
magic in my mind is our community it's
just so it's super special and part of
that for most folks the community they
experience is in their own affiliate and
that's awesome and amazing but there's
also this other community of millions of
people and when you go to an event like
the games I remember walking around last
year probably day three for me and thing
thinking to myself there are few places
right you could draw a ring around
the games right now this event and there
are probably not another 15 000 human
beings who are happier healthier fitter
more resilient on the planet anywhere
and you walk around and you see people
the the level of happiness and
excitement and standing in stark
contrast to what you see sadly in most
of our society but that really struck me
so it's just a super fun high energy
positive environment we've got a really
we've done a lot of work to build out
experiences for the fans so we'll have
uh throw down training sessions where we
effectively allow fans to do similar
workouts to what the elite athletes are
doing under conditions that feels like
you're getting after it I did one in
Berlin you have an announcer you have a
DJ you're doing the same I mean it is
that is as close as I'll ever get to
anything quasi-elite but it's super fun
and then we do a bunch of work for our
affiliate owners as well yeah that's a a
good point when you get around like I go
to Jiu-Jitsu events and you get that
same thing because everyone there's is
99 of the people there are training and
they're in good shape and they're
working hard and just like you know the
Marine Corps said what I opened with and
just like I wrote about in in discipline
freedom field manual and just actually
one of the most key things that Echo
Charles ever said on this podcast was
there's nothing that there's nothing
that you can do
in life that's going to positively
impact more other things in your life
than exercise like if you're a person
and you don't work out you know that was
another thing I was considering reading
on this was there's a the opening of the
book starting strength and in the
opening the book starting strength he
basically says like
hey I understand that people are out
there doing their jobs and maybe you're
an accountant and maybe you're doing a
good job with that but and and no one
would say that this guy's unhappy
because he's an accountant but wouldn't
he be more happy if he had a 405 Squad
always it's like yes you will be happier
you'll be a happier human so that's uh
that's a good way to go
um what else man does that get us up to
date I think so yeah next week next week
will be good to have you there yeah um
we have a partnership with Jocko Fuel
and Crossfit which has been freaking
awesome amazing awesome awesome to
launch again we I go to events you know
I just did a couple Live Events and we
did Detroit we did Chicago we did Boston
we did Philly and it's the same thing
like people are in the game people are
trying to get better and you can just
see the attitudes of the people there we
always have to warn
our like when we do events at Echelon
front we do events
we'll tell the hotel
like hey just so you know we're opening
the doors at eight people will be
outside you know an hour and a half
earlier and we're doing a PT at 4 30 in
the morning or 4 45 in the morning
they're like what are you talking about
there is anyone gonna go with you we
will say yeah 900 people are going to be
out there and they don't understand it
yeah because it's a different group of
people and again when you have people
that are focused when you have people
that are that are exercising and being
able to exercise with other people and
being in a friendly yet competitive
environment and pushing each other and
pushing themselves
it's a win 100 people are showing up
that early excited to do really hard
yeah and walk out the other end of
it just buzzed yeah and you've got to
remember how good that's gonna make you
feel when you get done because
prior to and during sometimes don't feel
too good right sometimes those squats
get a little bit painful for sure
uh so for where can we find where can we
find you right you're on Twitter I'm on
Twitter
um and despite having worked in social
media I went to my wife's great Chagrin
I think I have 12 Instagram posts since
2012. your your game is weak my game is
extremely check out your Twitter I
checked out your Instagram I checked out
your Facebook for a guy that worked at
Google and Facebook and pin maybe are
you hiding on Pinterest mommy maybe
you're not gonna find me though I'll
tell you that right now
um but you're there but I guess if
people really want to know what's going
on with what we're talking about it's
it's at CrossFit that's right so
crossfit.com it's at CrossFit they're on
all social media platforms they got the
YouTube channel apparently the website's
being improved as we speak that's right
things are moving in the right direction
and
um that's what we're doing that's what
we're doing Echo Charles yes
what do you got you got any questions uh
yeah kind of late late questions
um so I've been to a few CrossFit Gyms
and but all the times that I've went
with the exception of this one here
um it there was like an actual like
class going on yep can you just roll in
and do your own workout or like how did
your dish so the tree for most folks who
are getting started with Crossfit the
traditional thing is you'll show up if
you've not done CrossFit before
um each gym is a little bit different
but a lot of gyms will have kind of an
onboarding class or session sometimes
it's one-on-one and if you're not
familiar with Olympic lifting for
example
um the coach will walk you through kind
of the fundamentals you know everything
comes down to down to you know CrossFit
making sure you get the mechanics right
getting them consistent before you
introduce any sort of load or intensity
and so there's usually an onboarding
class
that'll then graduate to and again it
depends on the gym but graduate into
folks jumping right into sessions and
again the beauty of CrossFit is you
could be doing a class it could be your
third day where you're super unfamiliar
and you could be training some next to
someone who's going to the CrossFit
Games in their age group and the nature
of how that class is run and how it's
scaled makes it it possible for folks to
train together in a way that feels
really comfortable motivating Etc most
gyms also have open gym time so for a
lot of folks if they want to do
accessory work or some additional that
you can schedule that as well if I go on
a CrossFit gym on open open that time
open gym and I do curls in the squat
rack bonus points can I still come oh
okay bicep curls are universally praised
in every sport methodology so all right
so I'll still be allowed back foreign
I would encourage I've been to CrossFit
Gyms where they have open gym I I'm so
happy when they have open gym I would
encourage if you have a CrossFit gym to
have open gym as much as possible time
as you can uh and I think that's very
helpful there are some gyms usually it's
when they're really small
um they don't they don't have any open
gym but
I would encourage you to have open gym I
think it's healthy I think it's healthy
to be getting in there and
you know it's not not going to get to
train too much right what you find too
with open gym is I think one of the cool
things about CrossFit is you've got this
constant journey of getting better and
there's so much you know potential
complexity and advancement in everything
you do so you're going to find games
athletes who are still working on at the
very highest level who are still working
on some of their gymnastics movements
and when you get started so for me I've
been doing it nine years now I do open
gym because there's a few weaknesses I
want to work on and so you're constantly
thinking about okay like my ring muscle
ups suck I am not good at them I'm gonna
get some extra time so I can start to
work on it and you start to develop that
attitude within it where it's constant
progression and evolution yeah uh
anything else yeah you know I would say
over the years I have gotten Echo
Charles to start doing metabolic
conditioning do I get credit for the Met
cons you do I do get credit for that
what's your favorite workout or least
favorite
well yeah what is a metcon an actual
workout like any type it's yeah like a
like a wad metabolic conditioning it's a
variety of different stuff high heart
rate yeah yeah so just circuit training
still yeah kettlebells actually my
favorite one are you asking me what my
favorite one is okay so it's a circuit
of kettlebells if there's bicep curls in
here it's getting disqualified oh yeah
no I do the bicep curls before oh no
worries we're good to go uh kettlebell's
clean and jerk is it yeah
um so I go from that to burpees to
Jumping Jacks mountain climbers all
right legit yep how many how many rounds
do you do with that as many as they can
four or whatever sometimes it's like 25
minutes sometimes 25 minutes of that huh
yeah that's aggressive we don't even
we're not 100 sure if that's a metcon
anymore yeah I might just turn into like
you know but it goes as low as six
minutes too so what's worse what's
harder
what six minutes or 25 25 like 25 you
say that to me like I'm an idiot right
yes but here's the thing here's the
thing right
for me there's days where
six minutes is gonna be heinous but 25
is gonna be okay because I'm like going
to be able to like you're gonna you're
gonna have to back off a little bit Yeah
and then there's days where 25 minutes
is gonna be heinous and six minutes is
gonna be I'll I'll get some well okay so
and I get it I understand fully I I get
the um the six minutes even if it's
super hard usually it's like
under 10 like eight
eight and a half yeah that's usually
where it kind of sorts itself out
because it's a perfect in my opinion the
perfect balance of like actual the
strength part of it you know the 25
minutes that's like I'm using
lightweight it's kind of like a more of
a cardio thing yeah but I get super
bored with that so once you've reach
like the 15 minute Mark I'm like bro
this just sucks it's not even fun
anymore the six minutes is like sure it
gets sweet it can get super hard but at
least it's kind of exciting in there at
least you got to get yourself fired up
you know I'd way rather endure that than
the boredom part of it what do you think
uh the really short workouts for worse
for me like doing a Fram which is like a
three to four minute just like your
lungs hurt for you know you're rolling
on the floor those are the worst
workouts for me yeah all day those are
no those are horrible and glorious at
the same time yeah they're more exciting
though right don't you get like more
fired up for that for sure like that I
agree with you on the board of piece
it's a different type of grind yeah yeah
it is weird how emotionally I'm going to
say that word yes sir emotionally for a
like a four minute frame emotionally the
first minute and a half is actually just
no factor and you're kind of like oh I'm
I'm a badass and then you get hit in the
face with a baseball bat and you're like
I want to die yeah and you know you can
do more and they hurt so bad
did you run track before I did my wife
did yeah so there's a there's a race to
400 meter and they would say that that's
like the worst one yeah because it's
right in the zone I thought they said
the 800 meters the worst one well in I
don't know and maybe in uh when you get
a higher level for sure but in high
school it's 800 is kind of more of a
distance kind of scenario I'm sure it
would suck but because the 400 once you
get past 200 meter
you're just like holding on you leave
your body yeah it's like harsh man yeah
I think the professionals it becomes 800
meters because they become so
conditioned yeah but I think for them
they get to the 400 meter and they got
another 400 to go and it's a complete
freaking utter nightmare yeah yeah so
you don't want none of that apparently
no uh
Don you got any closing thoughts just
thank you guys really appreciate the
opportunity yeah well
thanks for coming down and I'm sure
we'll be seeing more of you in the
future and I look forward to seeing you
out at the games that'll be fun and um
thanks for coming out thanks for sharing
your experiences I mean that's a a
pretty wild ride you've been on so far
and I know you're just getting warmed up
and thanks for sharing your lesson
learned and of course thanks for your
service in the Marine Corps you know
um can't ever underestimate when people
step up and serve their country so
thanks for doing that don't likewise and
of course uh thanks for doing what
you're doing doing today to help people
get stronger faster and healthier love
it appreciate it guys appreciate it
and with that
done fall has left the building
so
looks like we're working out looks like
we're doing met cons looks like we're
getting stronger looks like we're
pushing each other looks like we're
rolling into the box the CrossFit
getting after it
that means you're gonna need some fuel
yep some feel for that evolution
a good place to get fuel the right fuel
the clean fuel Jocko fuel
dockerfield.com get some Mulk which is
protein they're they're a little bit mad
at me who uh
uh everyone at Jocko fuel okay
especially Joe Moss does that make sense
well I'll tell you why because
I called the protein Mulk right which is
its own word its own name
and people don't know what it is yeah
initially so unfortunately for the team
they have to explain it a thousand times
yeah okay they go do you guys want Mulk
in your store and they go what's milk
they say it's protein they say yes yeah
that took them an extra three seconds
okay can be a pain right after your 17th
000th time but for you out there you you
should know what Mulk is if you don't
it's protein clean protein tasty protein
dessert protein
you can get it in powder form pow pow or
you can get it or you can get it in
ready to drink form
whichever form you get it in it will
take out take you out of your catabolic
state where your your body is destroying
itself and will start to build and
rebuild
so you can get some of that so it works
hey here's a here's a tip I'm not a tip
like Earth tip but
what you do is you call it Mulk protein
yeah that's what we try to do now yeah
smoke protein because actually they have
a point if you're if if we're just
saying Mulk and you know how you just
kind of implied oh it takes three
seconds or whatever which I did I dig it
no this is a viable this is I I what's
the word I downplayed it but it's a
legitimate thing so you're correct so go
ahead yeah because you know how when you
um when you inundate someone's brain
with decisions right they start to get
um like diminish what do you call like
the their decision making like people
don't want to make a bunch of decisions
that's why if you have a menu with like
a million items it's like you risk
selling nothing kind of a thing but yeah
so if you're like hey you want some Mulk
it's like Frick I don't let me think I
don't know do I don't I don't even know
what that means now you just you're
giving them a decision fatigue just from
from that one little unnecessary time
yeah see I'm saying and and especially
if you're in a sales situation there's
what's it called sales resistance or
sales the thing where you know someone's
selling you something so you
automatically have your fence up it's
called something I think it's like sales
resistance or whatever okay so if you're
like hey you want some milk in your
thing the sales resistance is up because
I don't even know what that is stop
trying to sell me something I don't need
you know the resistance is is going to
be way more up but if you say Hey you
want some more protein or you want some
protein powder it's like wait we might
you see I'm saying the resistance is not
as as much this is this is why this is
my fault obviously you know and here was
my little
rationalization when this happened well
that was the second thing no when I made
up the name Mork oh got it for me Mulk
that it tasted so good yeah and it was
so good for you to me it was a different
thing like protein shakes taste bad
milkshakes aren't good for you we had
something new it tastes good and it was
good for you it's something new we need
a new name for it and in my mind I was
this is gonna be like a xerox machine so
you know how people say hey can you make
me as Xerox of this people needed
something a different name for it yeah
because it was so different or like
people say oh can you pass me a Kleenex
that's the name brand I thought the
world all over the world people be like
hey I need a Mulk not a protein shake
because they didn't want that and not a
milkshake because they don't want that
they're gonna be like oh I need a Mulk
just what we call it now yeah so in my
little infantile brain that's what I
thought would happen what I should have
done something similar is energy drinks
because our energy drink
is truly good for you
truly good for you and yet when people
think energy drinks they think bad for
you they think chemicals they think high
caffeine
they think sugar yeah and we don't have
sugar we don't have chemicals and we
have a good serviceable good for you
level of caffeine yeah so it's a good
thing but we didn't make up a word for
the energy drinks well maybe I should
have maybe you still can okay so we have
you know what uh apparently in the
streets Oh Yeah from the field yeah uh
in in Philly coming back from Jocko live
they call it Jaco
they call it one word like Jocko oh yeah
oh you got the Jocko drink yeah yeah so
it's like Jocko but they say go kind of
Jocko like oh you got that jog Oak drink
they say in one word so there's the
people
has legs that's what they're calling it
right yeah so
maybe I made a mistake with the milk
maybe I made a mistake by not coming up
with something better for the energy
drink but these are the mistakes that
I've made I apologize well we appreciate
you working with us to take what's good
for you you know uh we got joint health
stuff joint Warfare we got super krill
oil we got
you know immunity Cold War cold Wars if
you're on the road take Cold War it's
like 100 good to go yeah you don't you
go and shake a bunch you're sitting in
an airplane shaking a bunch of hands
like what you're doing you're getting
your disease
you gotta fend it off yeah so Draco
fuel.com
check it out we got everything that you
need on there
you can get it at Wawa
Slim Pickens at Wawa due to the the the
beverage Empires that are out there
trying to shut down the rebels they're
buying all the slots that's what's
happening we're hanging in there but in
the meantime vitamin shop GNC military
Commerce commissaries AAFES Hannaford's
Hannaford's going hot
Dash doors wake foreign ShopRite H-E-B
HEB in Texas hey thank you HEB and thank
you state of Texas Troopers folks that
are out there in the game just going in
we're crushing an HEB so thank you same
thing with Meyer up in the Midwest
Harris Teeter we got Lifetime Fitness
Shields and look CrossFit we're talking
about CrossFit today if you want to sell
this product in your gym
email JF sales at jockoffool.com
and we can get it in there for you get
you maybe get you a little refrigerator
you can just have it ready to go same
thing where you got a little Jiu Jitsu
Academy you got that Academy you want to
sell some good stuff you want to help
your
clients help your students
and you help yourself because you know
it's another little bit of an income
stream right so let's get let's make it
happen there you go that's what we're
doing chocolate fuel.com yep also origin
USA these are this is where you can get
your Okay RTX run train
everything else execute is execute I
think I say execute I think maybe Pete
says it's like an X like yeah like a
variable yeah hell yeah yeah I like that
one I guess execute's cool too but isn't
isn't executed e
yeah X it's like trendy it's like him I
don't know either way it's athletic gear
yeah it is but yeah cool athletic gear
good that is very good but it's all made
in America which is even better it's
like adds the additional but also they
got some Jujitsu stuff on there geez and
rashes some Jiu Jitsu stuff yeah they
got all Jiu Jitsu stuff yes what else do
you need from jiu jitsu
that you can't buy at origin you get the
key you get the rash guard you get the
shorts yep that's right you're ready to
go yeah I just meant it as there's some
Juju you go to originusa.com you can get
the RTX stuff you can get the Jiu Jitsu
stuff specifically for jujitsu then you
also got the jeans the boots you see I'm
saying so I say some that's just part of
what origin offers is what I'm saying
what I'm implying I don't know I don't
know why my son asked me this the other
day but he said how many times have you
worked out in pants in sweatpants in
your life yeah
oh no he said when's the last time you
worked out of sweatpants that's what it
was yeah I said I don't think I've
worked out with sweatpants in in at
least a decade and I don't think I've
ever worn pants sweatpants while working
out three times in my entire life
damn all right yeah my legs don't get
cold but if your legs get cold which
maybe your legs a little bit more
[Music]
aerodynamic
you know what I mean like a little bit I
know what you mean thank you some people
think you have skinny days
yeah maybe they get cold okay yeah
joggers yeah well here's the thing if
it's cold well it's not necessarily Oh
my legs feel cold it's not that it's for
like hey when you're warming up like
okay you ever worked out in a sweater or
not a sweater like a hoodie or something
like this you have most stuff yeah why
because keep my upper body get my upper
body warmed up warmed up for that
workout yeah same same deal okay right
you're doing some squats some deep
squats better be warm than not warm I'll
tell you that better be loose than not
loose and stiff okay maybe I need to
give a shot that's the justification of
them
ah so there you go go to originusa.com
get some American made
quality
make it happen make it happen also
jockostory.com this is where you can get
your discipline equals Freedom shirts
hats some hoodies on there some
accessories on there you want a flag you
want to flag fly the flag of discipline
we got one on there the death core flag
death core flag X flag even that's when
you're going deep right there the X
Flags actually a lot of people have that
one it's a good one um also there's the
shirt Locker which is a new shirt ever a
lot of Representatives of the shirt
Locker at Jocko Live this past weekend I
saw a comment in it said oh I don't see
many shirt Locker shirts because I
posted a picture or something I don't
know what
moment I caught but that was there was
shirt Locker shirts in a big way it was
pretty awesome oh yeah yes I would go so
far as to say
40 of the people at these gigs were
representing while on the path that's
what it felt like I would have guessed
40 right yep that might be a little bit
high but not too high no it was well the
people I saw I mean granted I didn't
look at what everyone was wearing but
the the frequency in which boom was uh
it was hitting me yeah I think pretty
awesome yeah very good but if you don't
know what this is it's a new shirt it's
a new shirt every month different
designs that represent the path in
various ways
one of them which a guy was wearing by
the way I got like literally scolded for
for what for one of the designs oh yeah
yeah the don't f it up one yeah but it
just said don't f with the flag there
was a k so I guess there's an implied
swear word there uh it up yeah pretty
big but kind of muted though it's not
all bold or whatever it's kind of muted
a little bit but nonetheless that's just
that that was the most controversial one
I'm not a hundred percent sure if that
shirt would have passed my
scrutiny yeah well but I think it
probably would have you think so you
know because occasionally
you got to go outside the box just a
little bit Yeah well to me when the
reason that
it probably wouldn't affect the first
complaint I got I was like ah I think
he's right you know like I was always
sketched about those swearing wearing
shirts with swearing on it yeah but then
again probably there's more people than
me just me you know there's a lot
there's some of them that I'm like bro
this one is gonna Latin but everyone's
gonna love this is the best one this is
the best one and then people won't like
it and then there's ones that I'm like
okay this one's cool but you know people
really dig it yeah exactly right so you
just never know everybody's different
and that's kind of part of the reason
for this whole thing whereas you get a
wide variety of cool stuff in my opinion
hey look you're gonna find something
cool see I'm saying even if you don't
think every single one is cool
[Music]
that's where you can check them out they
also check out primalbeef.com
primalbeef.com we got Sean glass
veteran
former seal officer and he has got a
little
little beef thing going out there they
got Ribeyes on there they got rib eyes
primalbeef.com and it's one of these
things where you can order like a an
assortment of meat yeah they got a bunch
of different ways they got a kick-ass
packaging thing set up I already got my
first box and this meat is good GTG you
know what that means yes I do yeah of
course this meat is A Cut Above GTG
freaking good to go so go on there you
want to support veterans you want to
support like good farming
go ahead and check it out
primalbeef.com get yourself some steak
get yourself some burgers get yourself
some some beef hot dogs that's what
we're doing here we go also uh subscribe
to the podcast because we're here
we used to argue about whether it was
worth saying that yeah for about
probably 90 episodes yeah I'd say why
are we still saying this yeah and yet I
just said it and now it's been 397
episodes
so anyway subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't yet and also subscribe to
Jocko underground we just got done
recording a new job Jack on the ground
talking about compromise and we talk
about all kinds of subjects on there we
also answer a bunch of questions
subscribe to that Jocko underground.com
also YouTube channel also psychological
warfare also
flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Meyer making
cool stuff for you to hang on your wall
we got a bunch of books
we got you know what I haven't talked
about the ABCs of Jiu Jitsu by by coach
Adam Mason the same coach Adam from way
of the warrior kid is that the same
battle Yeah coach Adam and Chris ehlers
who's another Jiu Jitsu guy did all the
artwork he's a tattoo artist but he's
also a sick just Artist Artist he did
the artwork in there and where would you
where does this book land it's it's like
not quite a kid's book
but it is a kids book it's not quite an
adult book but it is an adult book it's
just like it's for everyone I guess and
if you this is actually one of the
things I noticed when I was kind of
going all through it like halfway I'm
like wait a second is this a coloring
book too and you know what he said it
can be can be the thing is the art alone
is
it's the kind of art you could just hang
on the wall yeah in fact we should maybe
we should offer some prints yeah anyways
um check it out ABC's of Jiu Jitsu also
I wrote a bunch of books too you can
check those out finals pen leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual code
evaluation protocols discipline to go
Freedom map funeral Field Manual way the
warrior kid let's get those for every
kid that you know
I signed so many way of the warrior kid
books and little warrior kids were
coming out to the Live Events and I'm
talking about some heavy stuff in those
things I'm talking about life death
disease
trauma
and these kids are there in the front
row big eyes taking notes what's up
Warrior kids so check all that out
plus we got hackworth signed a bunch of
hack worth a bunch of about face
obviously extreme ownership dichotomy of
leadership Channel those books
and speaking of dichotomy of leadership
and extreme ownership we have a
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com we sold out the Dallas
gig the Dallas muster there's still a
few slots left for FTX individual FTX
down in Texas that JP's running and
going go go and engage in combat
situations simulated combat situations
and learn how to lead
check that out we got the women's
assembly coming up which is September
14th through the 16th in Phoenix Arizona
Jamie Cochran was getting pictures taken
with people they know who she is they
understand that she understands
so go check that out
you can find all of this stuff and plus
you can find out about our consulting
services at echelonfront.com we also
have an online Academy
so you can learn about leadership while
you're sitting in the comfort of your
home
you don't have to pay some crazy amount
of money to travel you don't have to
bring in Echelon front to your
organization you can just go to extreme
ownership.com and you can take
courses you can ask questions on live
sessions we've got all kinds of
incredible ways to teach you the skills
of leadership that you can apply
you can apply with your
boss you can apply with your peers you
can apply with your subordinates you can
apply with your husband you can apply
with your wife you can apply with your
kids
you will learn how to lead and will make
every aspect of your life better
extreme ownership.com and if you want to
help service members active and retired
you want to help their families you want
to help gold star families check out
Mark Lee's mom mama Lee She's Got an
incredible charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org also you got Micah Fink he's got
Heroes and horses dot org he just got a
group out of the field they spent 41
days in the field getting reconnected
with their soul
it's an awesome program
and if you want to connect with us on
the interwebs of course we got
crossfit.com
if you want to check out this whole
CrossFit thing that we talked about
today all kinds of positive things will
come out of your life
if you start to get in better shape
if you start to connect with other
people that are in good shape if you
start to exercise and have a routine
this is all positive it's all going to
help you in every aspect of your life
and that's a quote from Echo Charles
so check out crossfit.com and go check
out the you know social media channels
at CrossFit and as well as Don who is
terrible despite working at Facebook
despite working at Pinterest despite
working at Google he's got nine
Instagram posts so go hassle him at dawn
fall it's d-o-n-f-a-u-l
and Echoes there as well he's Echo
Charles I am at Jocko willink and all
I'm going to say is look you can be a
good physical shape you can know jiu
jitsu
but you can get caught up by that
algorithm I know Echo Charles the other
day he was in the hotel he's in the
lobby
I came out I looked at him I saw him
he's wrapped in the algorithm the
algorithm had it by the throat by the
neck no it didn't bro oh yeah you were
wrapped up in the algorithm
don't all right well I mean hey man if
you say so but hey I deliberately seeked
sucked seeked sought sought out a
specific app okay so for those of you
that don't know and apparently we all
need to know this echo's going down the
the he's he's in the chess game right
now he's been playing chess he's on
chess.com what's your call sign your
Echo Charles 24. so if you want to
challenge Echo Charles 24 to a chess
match he's on their chest.com yep he is
looking to gain experience he's learned
a few lessons so far he's learned about
cover Move yep he's learned about
decentralized command these things are
all applicable yeah they're all
applicable yeah I'd say more so than I'm
looking for would you say I was looking
challenge matches yeah I'm looking for
challenge matches for sure I'm not
looking for uh experience looking for
the experience of the challenge match
Grudge Match
do you put money on these games no
I don't okay so there it is you can find
us and it's better that you play chess
than you are scrolling through the
ground it's true bro it was weird
because you know how like you stumble
onto something you're like oh yeah
you're kind of into it or whatever and
you don't realize where bro I wasn't on
Instagram for like two days not at all
not one single time for two days but I
was on I was on the chest not gone for
probably more than I should have been
but but still is better than Instagram
yeah and you got challenge matches going
with your son right is that what's
happening yeah with my son I just put
main tie on there and and Liam on there
bro don't put those guys on there they
got work to do I don't they need to be
editing videos yeah that's true so
that's gonna be on them you know they're
gonna exercise discipline same thing all
right well there we're at watch out for
the algorithm go to chess.com I guess is
what what we're doing Echo Charles 24
challenge matches let's go and uh thanks
once again to Don for coming on and for
his service and thanks to all our
service men and women out there who are
staying fit
stay fit
if you're in the military please get
after it
that way you are better prepared to
protect us and our freedoms also thanks
to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emt's
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders same message for you be in
shape
be fit
usually they have good deals to go to
CrossFit in your law enforcement your
police
Jiu Jitsu gym same things they people
take care of you in these communities
so go and check it out so you can do
your job better
and protect us which we thank you for
and everyone else out there you gotta
prioritize your health
that's what you got to do
you have to do everything that you
possibly can to maintain your health and
and it is a struggle
it's an uphill battle and the slope is
slippery
and listen you know what I understand
that there are things there absolutely
are things that we cannot control
there's wretched diseases that we cannot
control there are accidents that happen
that are beyond our control sometimes we
just have bad luck
but
remember that there is so much we can
control
so much that we can control
namely
what we eat
and how we exercise
and these are the two biggest things
that impact our health
so don't take your health for granted
make it truly make it your number one
priority every day
and and look if you go through a spell
where you got something going on and you
gotta you gotta refocus for a little
while a couple months goes by look I get
it we all go through times like that
we got a sick kid we got a project
that's going on we got things that
happen that are beyond our control but
listen don't let that become the norm
get back on the path
and you do that by going out there every
day
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out